the council
um
now
I know observing we have a
representative of IBA planning I think
last time it was Brian e Barracks but
can I just take your name
on Campbell
and and as I understand it you uh
primarily observing but you know
obviously if you do wish to speak at any
stages let me know
is there anyone else at this stage who
knows they'll wish
well I think everybody was just
basically a party but um if anybody's
wishes to speak at any stage just let me
know
now I ran through the details of the
appeals on the first day so I won't go
all through all of that again uh but by
way of a very brief recap Mr Robert had
filled appeals against two enforcement
notices issued by Northeast Derbyshire
District Council and the first one which
is the subject of appeal a concerns the
change of use material change of use of
a building to a single dwelling house
and the second which is the subject of
appeal B concerns the unauthorized
direction of two buildings one being a
garage the other an unfinished building
so I think of me interrupting you at the
beginning there has been some movement
outside the room in the last five
minutes of pla is gone the pla is gone
yeah
there's just to um just just so you're
aware from the outside all right okay
well obviously a pla was the the reason
for the public inquiry but as soon as
we're here
I mean the reason for the public inquiry
as opposed to
uh any other any other form of procedure
right okay well that's um if it's
helpful uh so I don't interrupt
procedure I obviously got a list of
appearances of qualifications I've also
got written opening submissions in which
I set out the position right uh and I
was going to explain uh that what we
were doing with the pla but you've been
told that anyway that's fine all right
thank you very much
so appeal b
um is proceeding on grounds a and F
namely that planning permissions should
be granted for the buildings and ground
f is that the requirements are going to
succeed uh what are excessive I'll come
back to the detail of that later now
initially there was also Appeal on
ground C but that has been
there's also movement on that
um again I'm setting this out in in
opening submissions but we seek to add
appeal G
in relation to time scale
oh God
no I know that's very late uh but for
reasons again which I explained I've
only been instructed uh this week and
was able to take instructions for the
first time yesterday and it's become
obvious to me that an appeal on Grant G
is necessary so there's going to be an
application to add in uh around you
foreign
submissions
um I mean obviously whether or not there
is a ground G appeal
I will always have the ability to
consider the question of time scales but
I'll hear anything that Mr light has got
to say about the the addition about
ground after openings in my respect for
you it's not going to hold things up
today it's a very simple question uh
which is going to be based on the uh the
the scan extent of the building and
materials and you'll have to perform a
view so I'm not expecting it to take a
very long at all okay so as I said
ground C's been with withdrawn uh and
that's confirmative ground
um
and also during the adjournment
um
and as anticipated in my adjournment no
to the sixth of September I'll have to
readjust what I'm saying as I go along
on the basis of the withdrawal of the
real name but just bear with me
um I've received a proof of evidence
from Mr Telford from the appellant for a
battle proof from Mr Hawley for the
council and that includes suggested
conditions
and I've received a written cost
application
from the council which I'm calling
inquiry document two
yes I have prepared a written response
uh to that application for costs which I
can hand in as well thank you
well still I take that now
I
need right okay
um
um
uh is I've responded to the the written
costs application so that's all I can do
uh and then if the council wants to make
a further application we'll do that in
due course uh it will be resisted but
let's see what they've got to say uh so
I don't know whether
uh in procedurally you want to deal with
this as a cost application as made and
as responded to and then have a further
consolidation or whether you would
prefer the council to to withdraw or to
uh have a single cost application with a
single response which can be dealt with
in writing after the event it seems to
me to keep it clean it would be better
to deal with the cost application that
was put in and the response and then for
a separate application to be made I
think given the issues and the way that
I've dealt with it I would I think
that's an easier thing well I think I
can come back to that at the very end
because I think um
to a certain extent it's not so much how
I would like to be with it but how you'd
like to present the application so once
you've had a chance to read what's said
you may be able to Simply add to what's
been in writing or no so we'll see but
that's what I was going to suggestion
thank you but I won't
stay and obviously with
I am
I set down certain time scales for
submission of various things when I
adjourned partly to make sure that we
deal with things as quickly as as
possible
um
on resumption obviously as far as costs
concerned whilst everybody's encouraged
to make applications early on and it's
useful to have responses early on things
can happen during the course of an
inquiry which inevitably leads to
changes to applications for costs or
even
costs applications that weren't
anticipated so
um I'm not going to make a big issue of
of
um a late response to a cost application
I'm just going to deal with it the best
way I can but obviously we've got more
time available now than I anticipated
when we first set all this this out yes
I'm grateful for that I just repeating
myself
um I was only instructed uh on Monday so
yes it's regrettable that the response
wasn't so put in but it's got to be
right and proportionate that the
appellant is given the the full chance
to respond it's not going to hold things
up so thank you very much for that so
that's now inquiry document four so just
to be clear obviously you weren't
involved Mr hardy at the outset but the
inquiry document one was simply the plan
attached to the planning contribution
notice of the 7th of October 22. yeah
document two was the council's written
costs application and appendices
statement three is the statement of
common sorry inquiry document three is a
statement of common ground which I
received during the adjournment and now
we have four which is the written costs
uh response
now um yesterday I was also provided
with a couple of further documents from
from the council which is a part one
landscape character description and then
a technical support document
now um during the round table session I
was going to ask for a little bit more
information
um in relation to the area of primary
landscape sensitivity
um but Mr hardy from your point of view
is there any
problem with my considering these uh no
and in fact the council provided me with
an electronic copy on Tuesday to say
that that is all good thank you okay so
they were submitted to um uh pins we we
noted in your agenda you'd ask for more
information or were intended to consider
for information on this and you thought
this was neutral information which
really is to you all right thank you
just to give you a heads up on on this
one
um
obviously I'm I'm bound to consider
National policy even if it's not raised
by by either the parties
um just so the advanced warning of it
one one thing I just want to consider
and touch upon is
um in the context of what we've just
been discussing the national planning
policy Frameworks approach to what it
called valued Landscapes and whether
that's that's relevant to what we're
considering here because there's been no
mention of it in the in the evidence
um but obviously this this reference the
era of primary landscape sensitivity
brings Bells as far as I'm concerned
with that and I'll just make sure
I need to take instructions on that
thing in the Germans yeah
acceptable
so um
that brings me back into the the inquiry
document list so if I if I call the
part one landscape character description
inquiry document five
foreign
document is six
so just to I was going to come back to
talk about the uh the inquiry procedure
but most of that's now
Irrelevant in terms of the procedure
that we we have left
um which is the Roundtable discussion on
uh ground on appeal B sorry
um you've very kindly given me time
estimates as well which are again no
longer really uh relevant investment
cross-examination Etc so as far as the
round table session is concerned um
you'll be aware that basically that's
just a
um a discussion led by me in the context
of the agenda which I have
um circulated I'll give you an
opportunity to comment on that agenda
shortly
but clearly the purpose is to enable
everybody to put their respective cases
to me and for me to gather the
information I need to make my uh
decisions
whilst I might Direct
questions to specific individuals
um
if it's more appropriate for anybody
else to answer then that's fine and
similarly
um
anybody who has got something useful say
on the issue you could just let me know
and I won't within reason to stop you
speaking
so unless there's anything
oh what I didn't deal with is that the
basic housekeeping of things like um
fire alarms and so on
um
can you just outline what the procedure
is in the events of a fire or other
emergency
and so in case there is a pads no
planned fire practice so you go straight
through there and it's the first
Cory go around the steps to your left
thank you
yeah well I yes so
um I was going to explain all that again
but I was slightly thrown off course by
it by having to abandon my my script
because of the withdrawal of appeal hey
I did have a look yesterday afternoon
um slightly dim and dingy in terms of
weather but it was still light enough
for me to see
and I
had a uh a look from milthorpe Lane
obviously you can't really see anything
of the
um appeal buildings from millthorpe Lane
as you
go from Milford Lane onto the private
driveway and at where the footpath joins
the private driveway I think it'll be
just about Glimpse the roofs of the um
unauthorized buildings as far as I could
tell
and then I went up the footpath
um I couldn't see anything of the
unauthorized buildings from the profile
I didn't walk very far up as far as the
topography was concerned the
um hedgerated trees and intervening
buildings it seemed that I wasn't going
to be able to see anything of the um
buildings from there I also looked from
New Road
where I could see the buildings um I
mean I stopped nearly 50 miles per hour
sign and I could see the buildings there
obviously there's an intervening
um hedge with trees in it um still
leaves on the trees but I could see the
buildings
um and I could see them against the
backdrop of the rising land hedgerated
trees Beyond behind that and buildings
behind that so that's what I've seen if
if there are other public Vantage points
that you want me to
consider then I will do so I haven't
there's been referenced to
um long distance views from the opposing
Hill slope
um but I haven't been anywhere else to
have a look from any any further
distance so if you want me to I'm
obviously willing to do that
we can come back to that one we
arrange the site inspection and
obviously I will be carrying out uh an
accompanied site inspection
as part of the
process
um
as far as that's concerned
um obviously normally with an inquiry
site visit there's no
discussion as such on site
this is still an inquiry albeit that
we're dealing with
the um the remaining Matters by way of a
round table
discussion
um
I suppose
procedure I suppose I could effectively
convert it to a hearing and deal with
discussion on site but I'd like to hear
whether anybody's got any any objectives
that in any event I want to hear all the
main arguments here here I don't want to
be trying to take notes of detailed
arguments on on site
my understanding is that this is it's an
inquiry uh so it's a Roundtable session
within that inquiry format I don't see
uh that there's any benefit in
converting that
I I agree since the recent um status
actually change I don't think you need
to convert this no to an area okay
but but on that basis Mr lighthead are
you saying you're that that it's
appropriate for me to continue
discussion on site
um
would there be a need to continue
discussion on I don't know I mean I
would have thought we at least as an A
in discussion you could take place in
the room
I mean the the other thing about this is
that um that brings it to question the
timing of the site visit it might be it
might be that it's appropriate to
adjourn to the site and then come back
further discussion it kind of depends on
how the discussion unfolds as to whether
that's going to be necessary or
beneficial but I'm just letting you know
I'm I'm more than willing to do that if
it's if it's the most sensible way of of
doing things so we're we're entitled in
your hands so that
I think
I think might be a good idea actually I
mean what we could do is have openings
are going to be short uh I think the
site's probably missing 20 minutes from
here so for you to go and see uh in
detail what we're talking about the
Roundtable session itself I can't think
it's going to take more than a couple of
hours so they're and also giving
lighting is better to go in the morning
so there is some utility either thought
in having opening sick going to see
inside coming back
um
yeah it's a sort of double it's a long
expression but it's it's um there are
pros and cons in the sense that
um sometimes it's very useful in when
we're having a discussion to have seen
things in detail on site sometimes it's
very useful when you go on site to have
the detailed discussion now so that you
know exactly what you what you need to
be looking at
um so rather not have two sites visit so
I can avoid it but I think we'll play
that one by
um it what do you think Mr Mr lighthead
do you think it would be appropriate to
have the site visit before uh any of the
discussion so I I think well I can take
instructions I I doubt we have a strong
view on it says whatever would most
assists you yeah yeah
I think I think I'd like to get on with
the discussion and if if it turns out
that actually
we're getting over this I'd like to see
the site before we go further than I'll
turn to the site
um I mean obviously I have seen
I've seen the area
so
um I'll play play it by you if that's
all right right with you thank you sir
well I'd hope we'd finished the RTS by
by lunch anyway so you'll be able to go
at two o'clock I think that it gets dark
doesn't it about but obviously yeah uh
so if we you know with 20 minutes
traveling time I suspect we'll be all
right dude in that way but obviously for
you
right okay thank you
so on the agenda
I have
um well I mean the first thing is that
it's agreed in the statement of common
ground that um that the development is
inappropriate development in the green
belt
and I take it there's no no change on
that score
um
as far as
um
the main issues are concerned are you
happy that I have properly articulated
those
on the agenda
yes
good
so first of all
if I can direct this one at the council
first of all I don't know whether it's
going to be Mr Hawley almost tonight had
the answers or a combination for both
but that's fine one way or the other
um can you describe what you see as as
being the impact on the openness of the
green belt of both buildings so can I
just before we do that are we having any
submissions because sorry
because because it feels more like a
hearing now yes yes
sorry Mr hardy yes
and you have those in writing uh yes I
do
but I haven't this yet
thank you
thank you very much so that that now is
inquiry document seven
it's no I have it in writing on food
it's not been printed
um yes I don't know if you're going to
do that as long as I know that it's
going to happen I mean I don't have to
take confused notes it is also mostly
beautiful
thank you
yes Mr Harding so it might also come
with the added benefits of some ink
splodges on them I'm afraid my uh
printer was playing up that I forgive me
for that
um it's unfortunate that these
enforcement proceedings bear the
Hallmarks of heavy-handedness on the
part of the council uh they have caused
very considerable distress and upset to
the appellant and his family to the
point where the opponent does not feel
able to attend the proceedings today you
know the opponent is not here um
personally
now I've indicated that he should come
and I told him that yesterday if you
require him to attend but there is a
very real sense that the council has
singled him out the differential
treatment
it's a matter of considerable regret uh
that the council has refused to meet the
appellant to discuss a constructive uh
Way Forward that was something that was
encouraged on the last occasion and of
course that is the exhortation in
National policy guidance now the email
correspondence you can be shown that if
necessary uh that's between Mr Telford
and the council and I've seen that
actually uh that was a good idea and may
well have short-circuited some matters
and in my view was a senseful there
would have been a realistic prospective
of having a solution to these
proceedings in total but the council
said nope not doing that we're going to
carry on with these important
proceedings and that's the matter of
regret it's clear
that a sensible way could have been
negotiated but the opportunity to
discuss that way was dismissed outright
by the council so we're here we are
of course and at least for the moment uh
I say that perhaps tongue-in-cheek given
the uh Teresa villier's LED uh uh uh
Uprising uh planning is morally neutral
these appeals should be determined in
the normal way against the provisions of
the adopted development plan National
policy and other material considerations
so what do I mean by that look whatever
the council thinks of the panel
personally and there seems to be quite a
lot of heat uh these as far as the your
concerns secretary state is concerned
these need to be looked at in a
dispassionate way which I of course you
would I'm sorry to interrupt just to
make it clear
um
whatever heat there might be behind the
scenes
it's not been particularly apparent to
me in terms of what's been said said in
evidence and the other thing I just
wanted to check I should have waited to
the end but I'm very impatient
um when you said
um that the council has refused to meet
the appellant to discuss a constructive
way forward and this is something
encouraged on the last occasion
um it's not something that I encouraged
in the sense that I said or get together
and sort this out the only thing I
encouraged was the submission of estate
at the common ground which I got because
a risk of speaking out of certain
I'm not aware of any heat and it hasn't
been uh there has been no such refusal
so the point I'm trying to make is that
whatever has been going on behind the
scenes I've been doing this this job a
long time and I do just look at what the
planning flooding issues are and that's
what I will be doing so you don't have
to worry about that of course it wasn't
a director at you no but but but the
point is
um I mean we can provide the
correspondence that Mr light has just
wrong and I don't I don't need to see
that because it's not been put before me
so
well
that of course if if it's not helpful to
you but the the impression that's been
given by the council is that there
there's been no refusal to meet by um by
but on the part of the Council of course
that's not it is nationally encouraged
to to do that and that will and I do
with that in the cost claim as well so
factually that's right the Heat point is
one which the opponent has asked me to
make it's not something that concerns
you and I've made that very play so the
pla uh in discussion with the parent
yesterday actually the first time I was
able to take instructions uh it became
apparent that the occupant of Brynwood
Lodge uh has recently decided to pursue
her romantic relationship and is setting
up home with a partner so as a result
she'll be vacating the property
imminently so having reflected on the
matter as a result of that and the
appellant has reason to come to the view
that apparently no longer serves any
purpose so for that reason a pla is
withdrawn uh no need to call witness
evidence and that's going to shorten
proceedings greatly already know that
that's the case
so then turning to appeal B
grounds repeal are now grounds a and F
and I have already indicated that the
ground G having information which has
come uh to light uh even since I wrote
this yesterday I think ground G is going
to be uh necessary
and in summary then uh by way of opening
the product contends that Brynwood house
Brynwood Lodge are only seen in distance
views to the distribution of the South
they're viewed with a high hedge and the
rising around to the north forming a
backdrop that's the point that you've
already made
property is not visible from Milford
lane or the right of way any 112612 it's
only visible from new road to the South
where any views are broken through
substantial hedgerows and mature trees
again that's the point that you've
you've seen and made
both buildings are set into the bank
that forms the northern boundary of the
site
uh the oak framed and Oakland buildings
will weather into a silver gray finish
and are recessive buildings will sit in
gardens which to be landscaped and
airplanes will be softened
whatever the outcome of these appeals uh
the opponent retains his PD writing
class E and is able to construct
freestanding buildings which meet all
qualifying Criterion the tests relating
to ancillary use
that is a realistic fallback position
which will be exercised by the appellant
now whilst the appellant is not yet
applied for a Clopper and that will be
my advice that he does that before he
moves any buildings and that's not a
prerequisite the buildings are
constructed uh of such expensive
materials that they will be used now
I've taken instructions on that it's a
point that will come back to you
um but the um but the build cost
of the Oak Timber building uh it was 275
000 pounds it is extremely expensive
at the total cost the garage was about
125 000 in terms of build costs the
total bill cost of these two buildings
is 400 000. and removal alone I'm
informed by the appellant of the timber
frame building because it's such a
specialist job and that's the reason for
the appeal June uh is about 25 000
pounds to take it down
that money obviously isn't the uh the
real criteria in planning applications
which is important that's no because the
planning point is
you aren't just going to take these
things down and Skip themselves they're
very valuable materials and will be
reused so that's the fallback position
applying relevant case law in judgment
the area edge of red is the cartilage of
Brynwood house supported by the
investigations carried out by the
council in 2015 and alleged unauthorized
Earthworks formation of a swimming pool
basement room upon all of which are
within the curtainage as a result the
fallback position could take place
anywhere within the land
etched red
the current site and design of the
buildings is the most appropriate
location uh with the least the least
visual impact
should planning permission not be
granted for the garage the planet will
be required to plant multiple vehicles
at the Eastern end of the site on the
level area in front of where the garage
is now located and something that you
will see on site and something that I've
come to learn about the appellant is a
particular interest in most cars and
motor transport in general so it isn't
just a single car it's a gentleman with
a very extensive set of vehicles and
they include very high value sports cars
they also include a very substantial RV
motorhome of the America I'm going to
call it the American type so it's I
think it's specially imported various
motorcycles and other other off-road
vehicles as well so it's not it's not
somebody that's just got a single car
actually there I think uh it's about 10.
uh and those uh vehicles to be parked uh
will be parked at the Eastern end of the
site on the leveled area in front of
where the garage is now located
could be visible from the south and
across the valley where Vehicles will be
more conspicuous than at the garage
what we say is the garage is a material
improvement over an open parking area
which already exists as part of the
cartilage we say it's clearly preferable
to have the well-designed and this is a
high quality construction high quality
materials well-designed garage over
those multiple Vehicles parked in the
open
um 12 I just want to to to to make a
correction as a text I've not had a
chance to to do that and this morning
and it's important because in the
council's application for costs
um and I borrow the language from there
and I shouldn't have done
um it refers to the unfinished building
it might be better to have a
I don't know Monica a and a b or a
garage in Building B but the council
refers to this as unfinished so it's on
page 11 of the cost application one of
the buildings it says is uh unfinished
and they call it the unfinished building
it wasn't completed by the time the
enforcement notice was served and cannot
be completed by a ground a appeal and I
referred to a case called Arnold that
you may be familiar with and that
doesn't apply
um for a number of reasons the
building's finished building
so
um I I I've referred to it as the
unfinishment but that's indescriptive
terms so when you say the building is
finished
are you saying it's finished now or it
was finished when the notice issued when
the notice was issued
that's my instruction
now obviously if I'm wrong about that
then I will uh I will deal with it but
my that my instruction is that that was
a building
within 336
uh of the of the ACT well the thing is
given the definition of a building an
unfinished building is still a building
but the point is is what can be granted
planning permission yes and what can be
granted planning permission under the
deemed application is simply what was
there no more than what was there at the
time of the whether you call it an
unfinished building or just a building I
mean a Folly is a building well it goes
a bit further than that doesn't it
because the in the case in Arnold what
it was it was a house residential event
they were look what the inspector there
was faced on the ground a was with three
options to finish and the question was
how do the PD rights subsist in relation
to a ground a now here if the building
was
um uh was built and was a building and
there's no planning permission required
for internal Works to finish that up and
that was done at the time enforcement
notice was served then there isn't a
normal problem that's the submission
so the way the council put it as a grant
from cosplay the opponent has acted
unreasonably in that one of the
buildings is unfinished The Unfinished
building
for what was not completed at the time
in the reserve cannot be completed by a
grand a appeal
and they rely on Arnold
so if in fact that was a building the
works that aren't required that um would
be required to finish that are internal
endowment barcode information then there
is no one on profitable that's the
solution well you know obviously we
could deal with the the issue about
whether it would be appropriate to Grant
planning permission for what's there
having regard to what could be done
without without further planning
permission but yes the basic point is
simply that I can't Grant
permission for
the completed building I can't Grant
permission for that
for a sorry when I say for if there are
further Works to be carried out
um so that there would be things that
don't form
part of what was there at the time of
the notice then I can't actually
information for it if you're saying well
I don't need to it doesn't matter they
can do it anyway well that's a different
matter yes exactly that's exactly well
that that's the book we'll come back to
that of course what you can do on the
team jet on the ground 18 is only Grant
planning permission for the breach as
it's alleged in the notice so that's
absolutely understood but it's just
meeting
um what the council appear to be making
as a as an Arnold Point uh and I don't
think it might be that arises but we can
we can perhaps come back to that what
what happened I mean it just eraser
I don't understand too many hairs
coursing but of course what what
happened in Arnold was he could have a
ground G you could extend the time
period to allow planning application to
be made but I'm not I'm not going there
yet because I don't think it's necessary
in Ireland that was a solution to um
unfinished works
um right back to my text so overall uh
retention of the garage would have
beneficial effects on the openness of
the Greenback when judged against the
alternative and the fallback position
with respect to the outbuilding and we
say that would justify its retention and
I mean the basic point is this this is a
um a very substantial and property uh
it's no question about that when you go
and see it and he's there this matters
too much for the most expensive house in
the postcode it's a big house it is
deserving of an appropriately sized
garage
for
um for storage of cars and uh for
protection uh of what our expensive
motor vehicles
so the the the the the Top Line position
is that a garage of these sorts of
proportions absolutely is uh befitting
of this proposal so in terms of
Greenville wider considerations a matter
of course for you uh and you alone you
can apply what weight you want to them
but the appointment submits that the
benefits would clearly outweigh the harm
caused by the definition of harm and any
other harm such that very special
circumstances would exist
um I deal with this point in my response
the cost application from the council
the council
um so denigrate the argument in relation
to ground a saying it's absolutely
hopeless and it's unreasonable to take
these sorts of points I have to say I
think that's a very unattractive
position for the council today
and there are good reasons why you may
disagree with the the reasons but
they're absolutely good reasons why a
VSC case can succeed in this case and
the appellant's got every right to come
here and put those to you and indeed
urged on you
because uh properly uh looked at we say
that the BSC apply to both buildings
uh right ground F uh seven at Ground a
fails only planet submits required to
masturbanese is sufficient to remedy the
breach steps required by the council are
excessive uh and then concluding remarks
based on the evidence that it will call
uh Mr Telephone obviously is here to
give the substantive evidence then the
appointment in due course respectfully
request the ground they should succeed
failing that ground F should succeed and
then ground G if that is added thank you
so I hope that's helpful that's all I
intend to say thank you
and I apologize for interrupting yeah
thank you
so this will be inquiry document a
thank you
thanks
for all the state
okay so obviously uh when these were
written we weren't aware
that I wasn't aware that the appends um
was withdrawing one of the appeals and
adding in a whole new ground
um so some changes will need to be made
um
these are the opening submissions on
half of the council in relation to the
appeals made by Mr Robert that Hadfield
um I won't read all of that we're
familiar with what PLM Hill B are
um I've then summarized at the grounds
um
and as discuss dependent no longer
relies on ground C the council's
evidence will be given primarily by Mr
Julian Hawley and I've also said Ms
Joanne Edwards though I'm not sure that
is uh now necessary
um
appeal Aid
um so you set out the issues appeal um
groundia has gone a pla has gone just to
comment on that um uh uh briefly
um and and we may return to it later the
appellant um has given
um
uh
uh has said this this morning
um in the cost application in their cost
responses so that you've seen it they've
described the appeal as hopeless we
agree with that
um
what they've said is that it I because I
obviously I haven't read the response to
the cost application did you say
if you say appeal a was hopeless yes
well I can forgive me if I'm wrong I'll
check uh what was said
2.16 so this is the response of the cost
response sorry two points one six yeah
first sentence this element of the claim
is hopeless which is cosplay
oh right okay so that's that's my
forgiveness
um that's that's that's I just
misunderstood that so this um
so the the explanation given for uh
withdrawing um the appeal at a minute to
ten the reason we were all here uh is
that the current
um
occupants
um is as decided to pursue a romantic
relationship and setting up home with
with her partner
um I understand I forgot that this was
discussed last time I've forgotten her
relationship to the impellencies
of the parents partner the daughter of
the appendix partner so so she's a a
family member and last time let's
discussed that this suggested ancillary
use of course whether she lives there or
not uh says nothing about
uh yeah they use I think this is more
relevant to a cost application yeah we
really has your we can come back to it
but the thing is it's mentioned as a a
as as a reason there's no reason why if
if
they uh maintain that uh the ability as
an independent residency is why can't we
rented out uh it was there temporarily
for a family member I wouldn't say
anymore because you might you might
encourage them to reintroduce the period
but it's um it's it
um
appeal B then uh ground a
uh so you appendix accepts the new
garage and I'm finished building both
represents inappropriate developments in
the green belt uh Steve you set up the
main issues which are then uh summarized
again in the further points for uh
discussion the council's already set out
in its cost application why this ground
has no reasonable prospects of success
um and and I simply refer you again to
those uh points I can go through them
again now if it would assist uh but it
it is a hopeless
um ground
okay ground death
um
again so you set out several points for
discussion uh there uh what what we
would say tonight is that um the
requirement to restore the land
generally the condition it was in is
entirely reasonable there is a question
here about which has dealt with prime
minister Hawley and his proof about the
hard standing and whether that should
actually be dealt with underground a
uh rather than ground f it is
development and and we say well property
that should be considered under on on on
underground day would go beyond the
scope of around f
um
and then just responding very briefly to
um a couple of points
uh made by
um Millennial friends
uh this um
there has been um Perhaps Perhaps it
will or won't produce correspondence
there hasn't been any heavy-handedness
there hasn't been so far as unaware any
heat uh with the appellants uh the
appends
um there hasn't been a refusal to meet
him and he could attend uh today if he
wants to
um as to um The Unfinished building
um it's and how it's described it's it's
no objection was taken by Mr Telford
um to this point over the last few
months we have referred to it in our
evidence as as the unfinished building
um there is a photograph of it
apparent on the day that the enforcement
noticed that notice B was issued a
paragraph 5.5
of um Mr hawley's uh proof
um it is
um quite plainly unfinished
um unless it's a very strange building
um
a point was made about internal work yes
that's true to a degree
but of course they can't substantially
affect the external appearance of the
building and it's very difficult to see
how internal works could be done without
affecting the external appearance of the
budding and that's of course something
which you would need to
take into account sir
um unless
unless I can assist you
further at the present time those are
the opening submissions on behalf of the
council
thank you very much
in relation to the the the meeting I'm
alone friend is persisting at this point
about it um I know we've discussed it
and you're going to say maybe that it's
relevant to cost application but I'm
concerned um because uh there is
correspondence I have seen uh suggesting
meeting and there's an outright refusal
to me so it may be in the cost
application or in a response to a
further cost application that we
attached that maybe that's the
appropriate place I think that is the
appropriate
I mean it's not a hint or there anyway
but seeing as the point was it was made
I have my instructions on that so I
don't agree with that it is here
well that let's just we can go back and
forth on this but that that come that
comes down to the question of whether
a meeting was would be likely to you
know resolve the issues or not which is
something I like to form a view on but I
think as I say that's entirely
I'd say that's entirely for the costs
yes rather than the merits so
right so I did jump the gun
I almost denying you the opportunity to
make open submissions but I had um Mr
Hawley I'd asked um if the council could
just set out what it sees as the impact
on openness and then again before I go
go and go any further
um I should just say as far as um the
progress of the event is is concerned um
I've been proposing to take a a break
probably around about
between 11 half past 11.
um
breaking for lunch if necessary around
one but I will take breaks as and when
you think necessary within reason
because I sometimes get carried away I'm
enjoying the proceedings so much I
forget what time it is so if you need a
break let me know
um and obviously we'll just arrange
things
as sensibly as we can to fit in the um
the site inspection thank you
thank you sir
um
so General openness consideration of
feedback I don't know whether the
microphone should be moved a bit further
yeah
so um the mppf and policy ss10 of the
Northeast Derbyshire local plan
sets out that the fundamental aim of
Greenbelt policy is to prevent urban
sprawl by keeping land permanently open
the essential characteristics of the
Green Belt being that openness and
permanence
the PPG the planning practice guidance
states that when assessing the impacts
on the openness of the green belt you
should take the Judgment based on the
circumstances and that's for the
decision maker
the courts have identified a number of
matters which may need to be taken into
account when making an assessment on
openness
this includes but isn't limited to a
spatial aspect on openness
and a spatial aspect essentially means
that it's the absence of development and
characterized by the lack of development
rather than development which is there
which is unobtrusive or screened in some
way
there's also a visual aspect on openness
and this is assessed in terms of what
can be seen by The Observer
that assessment is not just limited to
the main public viewpoints as an
observer might see an aside from a
neighboring land but also from within
the site itself and from other land in
The Wider safety
so there's a clear distinction between a
visual impact on openness and visual
impact in landscape character terms
the PPG also advises that the duration
of the development and its remediability
is a key consideration
so this is taken into account any
provision to return the land to its
original state or to an equivalent or
improved state of openness
and also the degree of activity that's
likely to be generated by any particular
development so that could be ancillary
activities traffic generation those kind
of things
so that's the the general stance on
openness as we would consider it
so as per your agenda sir which is to
take into account the impact on openness
of each building
um these are set out in section 3.5
13.5 of my proof of evidence
the um the new garage and if I may we
decided to
um name these buildings because the a
pla was for the conversion of a garage
and we felt that by causing two things a
carriage would just invite confusion
so the new garage which is located at
the Eastern end of the site
um we've calculated the volume of that
at 387 meters cubed
so in a spatial sense it increases the
footprint and volume of build
development on the land to a substantial
extent
so the effect upon the spatial aspect of
openness is substantially negative
it significantly increases the massive
build development which is highly
visible from the main public Highway
especially during the winter and spring
rolls when there's no leaf on any of the
trees this has been accepted by the
Abundant as being the case
um so it's highly visible within the
site and from immediately adjoining land
it permanently develops land which was
previously opened and absent of any
built development
and so it results in a reduction in
visual openness which is substantially
negative
it's also located a significant distance
away from brimwood house and introduces
facilitating features such as hard
standings on land that was previously
open
although it's not permanent further harm
is caused to openness as a result of the
domestic activities you know the
increased comings and goings of vehicles
to that part of the land
I mean ultimately it's a substantial
permanent built structure and the
impacts will endure for the long term
there's no reasonable Prospect
oh sorry I'm sorry apologies
so it's a substantial and permanent
building
yeah so it's a substantial permanent
structure
because impacts are going to endure for
the long term
and there's no reasonable Prospect the
land will be returned to its original
state or condition
which means there's no reasonable
Prospect of there being an improved
state of openness
so both the visual and spatial sense
the impact is is substantially negative
and it can only conflict with the
purposes of including land within the
Greenville
and you know the council has to place
great weight on that
thank you
so for me turn to the unfinished
building or is it well I think you'll
probably basically
we're here from the opponent on that and
then come back to you in the relation to
the other the other building
thank you sir um yes
they always do things wrong uh
[Music]
um
um
yes it's so easy to forget okay
um the uh the reason for building it in
that corn that was simply because it
could be dug into the to the bank to
improve the visual impact of it
um but it was also for the type of
vehicles that are housed in there
they're not vehicles that are used on a
daily basis so the large motorhome uh is
rolled out occasionally uh the horse box
is used as and when it's required
uh the collector's vehicle or the
Ferrari uh that's not used on a daily
basis the motorcycles that were in there
uh the van that parks in that area
um they're not used on a daily basis and
that's the reason why it was put in that
corner uh from a vehicle point of view
but as I said it would put in that
corner again because of the uh the best
place to reduce the visual impact I on
the other hand use my Ferrari every day
but
um when you say the vehicles were always
part what do you mean by always vehicle
uh Vehicles always parked at that end of
the site yeah but when you say always
when did that always begin
right
they were parked out at the time the
building was put up uh and that was the
reason why they were parked up in that
corner at that end
um but the purpose of putting it down so
that the vehicles that were being parked
up in that corner could be put
undercover and perfected
because there's no claim that there's a
four-year route or a 10-year rule claim
in this respect it's simply that the
vehicles were parked in that area
um and they've been replaced by the
building or their visual impact has been
replaced by the building
all right
um because obviously we've got we've got
the aerial photographs of Mr Mr hawley's
proof
um
which show the position sort of from
1999 yeah
2016 so it's page 22 starts at 2015 20
is 21 but then phase 22 that's figure 11
and uh figure 13 which is 20 Page 23.
foreign
photograph the uh photograph some
paragraphs 8.24
8.23 eight points yeah I think the 2017
folks I think they are vehicles on that
uh you can see on the right well yeah
the 2016.
uh photograph shows that looks like a
looks like a defender or a
lingerie but there and then you've got
the vehicles in a 2017 figure 13.
all right thank you okay uh Mr holy
didn't
um uh refer to the alternative uh to the
impact on the openness when it was
commenting uh and the impact of the
alternative is really the form of that
position
of the vehicles being parked in the open
uh which uh our opinion would have had
more of an adverse effect on the
character of the and the openness of the
green belt than the actual building
itself as far as that um I know
sometimes it's a bit artificial to sort
of
chop these things up into discrete
topics because they all tend to overlap
in terms of that fallback position
and the parking of vehicles in the open
um I think I was going to approach that
on the basis of it being part of your
case for very special circumstances
other considerations so at the moment
I'm focusing on what is the impact of
what is there now rather than well you
know what what's an alternative impact
so we will come back to that
yes
um uh the uh
that the appellant has gone to a lot of
trouble uh to make sure that that
building has the minimum minimal impact
uh on the openness uh yes it's a
building uh there was no building there
previously that was uh that's not denied
in any way at all
but the actual building itself
um uh has tried to maintain the openness
from certainly from around the site and
outside the side
um by its designed by the harkip roads
the timber material so that it Blends
into its background which continues to
rise behind it
so that that's the visual aspect as Mr
holy yeah
obviously we're dealing with the the
policy stuff um at the moment no
question uh in terms of openness there
is an impact on openness Sam Smith and
Oxford Farms you know you've got two
aspects to that the spatial and visual
um the I'm not talking about the the the
visual effects which probably comes in
in a sort of landscape and visual of the
harm
um consideration but
um even if you treat impact on openness
as a constant you then got to go on to
consider the purposes of uh for
including land in the green belt and
that you may form a view because this is
residential uh and cartilage that in
fact the the purposes this isn't
particularly high functioning uh Green
Mountain Land of course it's got its
designation I'm not not so demand from
that but beyond that this isn't high
functioning Green Belt land
and the the the the spatial impact uh is
limited to that extent and that's an
important exercise for you because
before you apply a substantial harm
you've got or the substantial weight
rather you've got to decide how much
harm there is before I obliged one yes
you've got to know what the ball of harm
is in Greenville terms I said sorry and
it's just that word before because if if
it's inappropriate development then it
automatically carries substantial weight
yes the question is whether there's
additional
um over and above that in principle or
with respect no
um the way I've actually just been doing
that quite early earlier this week
seems to me respectfully that you you
have to determine the amount of harm
before you apply the substantial weight
so to use an analogy uh say you're
looking at Heritage buildings which I
deal with a lot
very significant weight
should be attached to any harm
um if you go back to Obama matter and
what God would be able to have to say
there it's important to determine the
degree of harm the size of the ball of
harm if you like before you apply the
substantial weight but that's not what
people that's not what the framework
says because let's let's say let's say
there was no
I concluded there was a difficult to
envisage but there was no impact on
openness but it was nevertheless
inappropriate development what weight do
I attach to that well it'll be
definition yes it's to which to which I
must according to the framework attack
substantial weight yeah yes but in order
to to know how much weight you're
substantial weight has got to be
attached yes but you then have to you've
got to look at the degree of harm the
size of harm and that will you know what
what the Supreme Court had to say was
that is split into spatial a spatial
aspect a visual aspect and then you have
to look at the contribution that the
land makes to the five purposes of
including land of the green bar that
will tell you the ball of harm to which
you then apply your substantial weight I
accept that I have to look at those
things but I can't having looked at them
I can't then say ah but well because of
all those things it doesn't carry
substantial weight no it's absolutely
not that just so we're not not so cross
purposes and see to the green belt a lot
substantial weight so the amount exactly
exactly no no I've lost of course I
think this is really important
substantial weight that's the amount of
weight you would turn out you've got to
attach it to something you've got to
know the amount of harm that you've got
that will be the variable so you have to
know what the impact on openness is and
that could be great could be could could
be could be little and you have to know
what contribution to the five purposes
of including Land There are so to take
an exam just take it just just to break
up a second so
in the case I did earlier this week what
sober you've done is for each parcel of
land within the green Bowl they've
undertaken an analysis of the um the
contribution that that land makes to the
five purposes and they rigged it one to
five so they'll have a rating of you
know take take take take purpose three
encroachment they rated it on one to
five depending on how high that that was
they've done that because they
recognized quite rightly in my view that
you will have a variable but you have to
to look at
to give you the amount of harm before
you then go and apply the substantial
way that you're exhorted to do by uh by
by the mppa
so otherwise and for putting putting it
in another way otherwise you just have a
blanket look it's in the green but I've
seen appropriate constant you apply
substantial harm that's a substantial
way yeah but that is exactly what the
framework works I mean surely it's a
question of
I attack substantial weight to it but
the question is how substantial
for the minimum the minimum I attach to
it is substantial weight I think we're
at Cross purposes no with respect and I
can put legal submissions in if you if
you want substantial where it's the
constant you apply that yeah that's
given
but you can only apply that to whatever
amount of harm the Corpus of the Palm
that you've got I don't understand
then
if you want I mean I'll try and explain
I'm trying to explain again obviously I
can put in legal submissions if you want
the you have to decide
impact on openness yes and the degree of
that that is not a constant
still you can have a great impact on
openness spatial terms and visual terms
so if you've got a small degree of harm
a small Corpus of harm
and you're applying substantial weight
to that
that is going to give you a different
element for your VSC equation than if
you've got a large degree apart to which
you're applying substantial weight yeah
I don't I don't I don't I understand
that that point right
um but
um you know I mean I've only got to look
at the framework itself and yes
paragraph on
inappropriate development is by
definition harmful to Greenville and
should not be same very special
circumstances then 148 when considering
planning application local planning
authorities should ensure that
substantial weight is given to any harm
to the green belt of course so harm by
definition carry a substantial weight I
then look beyond that to see what
what additional harm what real harm
there is in terms of openness visual
impact Etc
by the respect no I mean that's what the
framework says but it isn't with respect
and it might be obviously read it and
that's what it says
then um what how do you how does it not
say that
I think maybe there's a a I'll try and
just communicate the point together and
maybe we'll then leave it to Legal
submissions so substantial weight is
attached that's the constant yep but you
need to know the amount of harm
that you've got
so when you're doing your equation
at the end very special circumstances
are only going to pertain if the wider
benefits of the scheme clearly outweigh
the definitional harm plus the only
other harm so in order to do that
equation very special circumstances is
the output that's that's the that's
that's what you know those circumstances
you will have where your benefits out
where your definition of what's your
regards you need to know how much to
harm your definitional harm you've got
you need to know how much of a harm
you've got yes right so to do that you
need to understand the impact on the
openness that could be great can be
small and then you need to understand
the uh the purposes of including that
within the green belt and they maybe it
may be high functioning Green Belt maybe
low functioning green bell you look at
that that gives you your harm to which
you then play your substantial weight
well okay I mean in a sense you seem to
be saying what I'm saying but every time
I say it you tell me I'm wrong just that
Mr lighthead is it have you got anything
to it on this absolutely can we open the
microphone on absolutely uh nothing so I
think you've got it absolutely right
the the other case I can put in on this
which is is David paulgates said
decision uh in relation to polls and say
there's a case uh which explains how
that's gone so if that's helpful so it
may be that we get to the same place but
analytically uh my
um my submissions remain
foreign
capacity and it's a limited visual
envelope which we say uh is obvious and
you've seen that on the side is it so
you'll look at that and decide the
degree of uh harm that you've got by
definition
right okay sorry obviously so we're
dealing with the next building then
whatever whatever we want to call it
well that's that's the only first ones
who forgive me so before before we move
on I've just um
today I I don't think they're really
need to go uh back over that oh is it
clearly the amount of harm is going to
be relevant to the balancing exercise
it's it's a fairly obvious Point
okay because I don't leave that no the
the case that I've done is insulted what
I was saying was that so we've done that
they've undertaken that exercise and
they've broken the harm down in the way
that I've explained but the principles
aren't based on a 2015 draft assessment
facility they're based on the Supreme
Court and they're based on the number of
High Court decisions including as I've
indicated the decision of Mr Justice
Holgate on the uh
thank you so you'll be well familiar
with these I I doubt you need my
assistance on that there's one other
point which came out of melon and
Friends uh uh submissions he said it's
it's in the cartilage of course that is
in uh that's a matter of dispute between
the parties it's within the ground C uh
evidence
um which has now gone because the
opponent considered
um so the council was was confused by
the appendix case and if you remember
considered the cartilage of both the
lodge and also Brynwood uh house the
council says it isn't within the
cartilage
right okay that that's just just just to
flag that point just in case
um there's any confusion that that was a
matter agreed
I may just clarify a couple of points
which have been said
um
in my view the aerial photos don't show
any evidence of vehicles being part of
that far end of the site
certainly not by the apparent anyway I
mean the photograph which was taken in
2016 was
this is set out in paragraph 8.20 of my
group
and this is on page 23.
yeah so this was taken when the council
went to investigate alleged building
operations just off the south side of
brimwood Lodge these are the the
swimming pool and Conservatory Works
which Mr Telford refers to
um these are quite clearly construction
and contractors vehicles and therefore
are only temporary
and I think if we're looking at the
purpose of the green belts and including
land within the green belt then that is
that is to prevent urban sprawl and you
know the garage in that location
cannot it can only be defined as Urban
as well
and therefore must conflict with the
purposes of including land within the
green belt
okay thank you
so if we just turn to the The Unfinished
building so so can I
things
the abilities
okay
it's our vehicles at that end of the
site and I'm not saying that they're in
the photograph in 2016 all of their
outstanding is there for them
um I'm saying in fact that Vehicles can
be parked there and have been parked
there recently and it can it could come
they could continue to be parked there
if the garage wasn't there and that was
the reason why we built the garage to
get those large Vehicles undercover
rather than being in the open and
prominent to the Views that the council
is saying uh from which you can see that
the garage so just to clarify I think
you'll have your needs that we've gone
from always to recently
well yeah I mean that's why I was asking
about what was meant what was meant by
always I mean but so you're relying on
the the the fact that Vehicles could
could always have been part there at
least since the home since the hard
standing was there
the vehicles I mean the vehicles were
parked there uh when you go today you
might find vehicles to park there still
um uh yeah but there'll be vehicles that
have been left there
um which would normally be in fact I
think the vehicles that are parked at
the moment are behind the uh the ones in
the open are behind the unfinished
building if it's referred to as that and
you'll see that when you go on site
today but Vehicles the horse box and the
large vehicles and the Land Rovers and
things like that were all sparked sorry
not always Park were recently parked at
that end of the site until until they
the garage is built
if I could just respond to that in my
view it's the location of that new
Carriage which invites those vehicles to
be parked out there
if the council was dealing with a
planning application one had been
submitted for a new garage you know and
it was really felt it was reasonably
incidental
we may want that location of the garage
much closer to the dwelling with a much
better spatial relationship with it and
we may want to impose conditions
limiting the kind of parking which takes
place out to the east
so I was argue that the parking the
vehicles out there is a consequence of
that new garage in its position
that isn't because sir and if the if the
council uh want to restrict open parking
at that end of the site now that the
garage is built and they're quite
entitled to apply for a condition to be
imposed should ground over granted
yeah I mean I think we
I would have some difficulty in
justifying
a condition as reasonable which says you
can't park out some Vehicles outside
your garage but you know
um most people do
um but really what it comes down to is
I've I've got to make an assessment of
the impact of the garage
um and the
and a comparison between that and the
impact of parking in in the open
and the likelihood of that occurring in
that location
obviously Mr Hall is made made a point
about the the um
the the difference between
a permanent structure and the parking of
vehicles
um I know what you say about Mr about
the appellants vehicles the nature of
them Etc
um but also I've got to take out the
fact that the appellant may not always
be there I'm not being
pessimistic about his chances of
survival I'm just saying if I could you
could sell the property within a month
for all I know you know so it's those
things I have to weigh up I'm not saying
it's a what you're saying is irrelevant
but that affects the weight that I
attach to it two things one's a very
practical thing I don't know what's
going on over there
quite quite distracting for us I don't
know
I don't know well actually it would
probably it's a paper shredder big lorry
that comes so if you came too long there
you go having said that it is it is 20
past 11 and so and we haven't we're just
about to come onto this other building
so if it might so the other point I was
going to make about the about the garage
in relation to your point was that
um yes of course it runs with the uh
runs with the lamp but at the point I
was like making you know only was that
this is very substantial property it is
uh you know value is not the matter for
you but it is a very valuable property
the kind of people who buy this property
are going to have cars
and they're going to have a you know
they're not going to be talking about
one you know full Fiesta uh so in terms
of appropriate proportionate
accommodation for cars uh whether
they're owned by the appellant or a
future occupier uh we say
um you know there's an important point
to take into account you're not dealing
with a uh a modic semi
right well I'll adjourn until
um half past
are you still are you still confident
that this Roundtable session may only
take two hours
[Laughter]
I love time estimates today
right it's okay right thank you
there's a couple of interested parties
yes here one forgive me I I've actually
completely forgotten her name uh but
she's a neighbor of
um
brynwood's house
um and and wishes to contribute to the
discussion right in fact how and when
she's able to do that is a matter of use
of yeah basically if you want to speak
just put your hand up and then and I'll
try and make sure I notice you
um yes because of the nature of this
it's a bit it's more it's less formal
than any inquiry so
um if I tell you that um you're saying
you're making a point at the wrong time
bear with me that will you know it
doesn't mean I'm going to stop you
speaking
right
yeah
I think she raised the point about
vehicles with with me whether that can
be made I I didn't we didn't discuss it
as any link but I think we said that it
would matter for you so when and how she
made well you may as well as we've been
discussing that you may as well mention
it now so sorry you you are
foreign
so where you I think where yesterday
near the 50 mile an hour sign
our house is the first one
okay
yes and I've ridden there in in there
now for nearly 25 years and it was just
a comment about the cars uh that drive
along the top uh um at the house at
Brynwood
um
and and that I've always parked there
and there aren't any cars that I've ever
seen
um in all the time that I've lived there
apart from some construction vehicles
and one um well it's a a mobile home fan
but we refer to as the Scooby-Doo
vehicle because it is quite bright it's
a white and green one uh which parked
there for about six months
during covid
um but apart from that there are no
vehicles because it's easy you can see
it from our house it's quite visible and
there are no vehicles that Park on there
foreign
Ty uh I've been down there
um I've got personal knowledge of
vehicles
been
you have got personality
um every occasion I've been down
recently when I say recently obviously
I've not been down this summer because
of circumstances but when I've been down
there prior to
um
not being able to get their vehicles
have been parked there in fact I've been
in the large American mobile home while
it's been parked there the horse box uh
parks along there and I think the horse
boxes are brown or silver and brown uh
vehicle you might see that today anyway
um but obviously I I don't dispute so
what's sad at all it's just that when
I've been there I've seen Vehicles
parked uh outside the garage between
where the building is now and the garage
itself
everything
okay thank you
thank
you
so referring to the unfinished building
so I've calculated the volume of this up
to about 600 square meters uh 600 cubic
meters sorry
so this building increases the footprint
and volume of built development on the
land to a substantial extent
which means that the effect upon the
spatial aspect of openness is
substantially negative
that significantly increases the mass
development which is highly visible from
the main public highway to the South
especially during the winter and spring
months
it's also highly visible from the land
itself and from immediately adjoining
funding
foreign
considerably above pre-existing
situation
which can only mean it results in a
reduction in visual openness which is
substantially negative
it's a substantial reduction in visual
openness when also considered
cumulatively with a new garage
and the extensions to grimwood house
foreign
just explain why I should I should
consider the extensions to Brentwood
house as part of that
foreign
well I mean I suppose you
ought to consider where we started from
in that this was a relatively small
property back in 2000 when planning
permission was granted for it to be
rebuilt
it wasn't rebuilt in accordance with the
plans
um which we I think we've accepted in
the statements of common ground
since that time it has been
substantially extended
and as indicated by Mr hardy it's
already the most expensive property in
this area
therefore in my view the cumulative
impact of all these extensions
ought to be consumed
so in visual terms the value of the
property is totally irrelevant
um
just explaining what happened with
Greenwood house it was a small property
it was granted planning consent for
substantial extensions and alterations
uh which were carried out but not in
accordance with the plans
so that they uh the the building that
resulted along with the garage
uh the council accepted without being
built in accordance with the plans uh
but they've accepted that that is the
original dwelling house
since then there are no extensions or
alterations to that how sorry no
extensions to the house at all
there's a large conservatory at the back
but there was a conservatory at the back
on the approved clones and the council
accepted that that Conservatory formed
party the original dwelling house all
that's happened is that it's been
refoced in stone
it's got a flat roof now instead of a an
apex room
and the hexagonal Corners were taken off
and it was squared up
but there was a conservatory in its
place and the council accepting uh that
what had been done didn't require
consent
below there was a void
which was dug out and the pace of it was
exposed and French doors were put on
there and now face out to a swimming
pool probably if I say at this point and
you can just tell me if I'm I'm wrong
but
I I think I'd be on dodgy ground put it
that way if I if I
um dismiss the appeal on the basis of
the impact on openness of these
extensions together with the extensions
permitted in relation to the the
dwelling that's the point I'm looking
I'm looking at the subjects of the
enforcement notices so I understand you
know I understand the point you're
making but I don't think it's one that I
could I could safely rely on
okay so just carrying on
um The Unfinished building is a
substantial permanent structure the
impacts of which will endure for the
long term
so there's no no provision or reasonable
Prospect the fund will be returned to
its original state
or to an equivalent or improved state of
openness
so in summary it has a significantly
negative effect
upon openness both spatially and
Visually
and therefore conflicts with the
purposes of including London Greenville
and of course the castle must attach
considerable weight
thank you
so in spatial terms the building uh is
much closer it can't be compared to the
garage it's much closer to Brentwood
House
and functionally it's well related to it
that site where it is now was a raised
parking area and you can see that from
one of the photographs in Mr all these
evidence
uh on that hard standing there were
several buildings uh and uh they
um buildings that were on there are
shown on various photographs certainly
the aerial photographs uh the buildings
can be seen and we have a photograph
that actually
uh shows and I'm quite happy to Handy
Sims uh
let me just have a look at what I've
already got and there's the photographer
figure nine
um of Mr Hall this group yeah
and figure seven is about three well
seven eight and nine
is that any different to what you were
going to show me there
no the photographs that are
um
uh shown on the the buildings that are
shown on the aerial photographs
uh very similar to the buildings that
were on this Photograph that's taken
from a different animal uh and it shows
those buildings
um
and uh what was the point I'm making is
that uh there were buildings on this
site previously even though they were
they were removed
um but uh there were buildings on the
site uh which is again different to the
argument for the garage
uh I'm not using the arguments that uh
that building is being put there as just
they're working my pins run outs okay
just simply
foreign
so those the buildings that were on that
part of the site as I say they're
they're shown in figures seven eight and
nine and uh on a rather blurred figure
10 but they're gone then by
your 11 2016. they were remote
the buildings did exist on that side I'm
hesitant to put in a photograph that the
um the council hasn't seen but I have a
photograph here which correlates it's
taken from a different angle but it
correlates I think pretty well with fig
and nine uh
I don't know whether my friend have any
objection to to putting that in are you
seeing I've only got one copy well I
think we need to say but if it
correlates does it add anything
uh well it gives some idea of uh of
height because that's difficult to tell
from a figure from figure you know I'll
show you anyway
facilities
I think it's a Google rendering I think
it's something that's available from
Google Earth you know it's automatically
populates the sounds
plan and it was possible to take
irrespective I think the starting
position is as shown prior to the
development taking place
and that's from 2016 onwards and that's
the Baseline that we ought to be
considering
again if I I often think it's helpful
for me to
to say what's on my mind not not because
I I my mind isn't closed it's just that
you can only
persuade me that I'm wrong if you know
what I'm thinking and so
um as far as the existence of buildings
prior to 2016 is concerned
um again it comes back to the question
of other considerations as part of a
very special circumstances so I would
say that Mr Hawley is is quite right
that the primary starting point is well
what was there before this development
was carried out but
um
what may have been there some years
before is not irrelevant to the question
it is capable of being another
consideration which I take into account
um you know if for many years land has
been occupied by huge buildings and then
they're demolished
and there's nothing on the site for a
year or so and then somebody builds
something else I don't think it's
irrelevant that the historical position
was it was covered with buildings it's a
matter of weight again I attached to all
these things but um I think that's right
and actually just looking at that the
photographs that you're going to get
um I'm saying Mr holler's point about
what was there before the works were
done actually figure 10
uh which is Page 21 of his proof that's
that that's his paragraph 8 16. you can
see that there's Disturbed uh
disturbance
um that's obvious on that photograph
that we've just you've got
um it doesn't say when that was taken in
2015 but you it may be that that is a
just trying to key it into
what was going on it clearly isn't it
isn't 2011 because obviously you've got
green
there's a grasp behind it where's the
photograph that you've got it's got the
the lighter color the light colored uh
Disturbed Earth behind it it may be that
that's closer to the 2015 Edition
I think my photographing figure 10 is
taken when the Earthworks are taking
place for the construction of the
swimming pool
yes I'm trying to it was just trying to
do just trying to be helpful is when you
see that there's there's obviously
yellow with Earth behind the those
buildings that we're talking about on
that photograph in 2015 there is some
disturbance of the ground behind that so
I I can't say when that was but it may
be that that's
seemed to key that the date of the
photographically put in it that's all
so you you you're suggesting that this
which I now call inquiry doc document 9
was probably around 2015.
yeah it's clearly not 2016 because
obviously gone but the buildings are
still there in 2015 and there is the
indication of disturbed I can't get it
any higher than that so this is just a
observation of questions we are I'm not
aware what those buildings are but uh
are we sure they're lawful
I don't think there's any planning
records for them
and that would also be relevant to yes
I don't think there's any record of any
planning pollution being granted for
this but the presumption of regularity
so unless the council wants to say
they're not then the positions that
they're taking to be lawful Mr hardy May
impose a presumption I don't think
there's any lawful presumption
assumption well I'm aware of the
presumption of regularity I've never
heard it yet cited in a planning of
people that's in relation to buildings
aggressive sense of evidence that that
it is an applicable principle
it's for the appellant to make this case
we don't know what these buildings are
how long they've been there I I mean
we're talking at the moment we're
talking about ground a so it's not about
the burden of proof being on the pennant
it's just about the balance of
probabilities but
um but
when this when deciding whether it's
I'm not I'm not sure I'm in a position
to conclude that it's they were probably
lawful because they were there
um I don't I'm not convinced about the
presumption of regularity in that
context the 2010
intense that's true and it shows I mean
2015 so if they're there between 2010
and 2015 they were there for four years
there were buildings in 2005 on that
yeah so that's that's more significant
than any any presumption I would say um
so if there were a presumption of
regularity then the burden of proof or
Penance in Enforcement cases wouldn't
apply
well it's only in relation to the point
where if there's no evidence the council
has no evidence about the cast that
raised a lack of laws we're going down
we're going down a rabbit hole but we're
not the point in cases of the rises
again the point I'm trying to make out
is if you if if there was an enforcement
Appeal on ground D and you're saying the
building was there for four years and
all you had to say was well there's a
presumption that it was there for four
years or that it's lawful then it would
change the nature of the game very
considerably
the four years is there anyway
sorry yes four years and he knew I think
that's where we are
and I'd argue that even against that
pre-existing situation in 2010 The
Unfinished building has built is
considerably bigger and has a much
greater impact on spatial opens
development would this beard does in any
way at all
right
the point I was making so was it's it's
more specially in spatial terms it's
more related to uh uh Brentwood house uh
uh
the the garage uh is as Mr Hawley was
was stating yeah when we talked about
the garage
I also make a point that Mr Hawley
says and again I'm not using it or we're
not using it as one of the exceptions
involvement in the green belt but it's
just a correction of something Mr Holy
says in one of his paragraphs that this
is this is not a previously developed
land
um
I would argue that in fact
this is a residential Garden a large
residential garden and because it's not
in a built-up area
uh it is uh not one of the exemptions in
the definition of previously developed
land in the nppf
so I would suggest that this residential
Garden uh and where this building is is
on previously developed land
and I'm very free today is it like it's
Dartford and the Secretary of State
uh in in that respect
right
um now it's a question of how far we
have to explore that because you said it
doesn't you're not relying on that as a
as a means of making it not
inappropriate development but again
um I suppose it's if it's previous if it
is previously developed and again that's
one of the other considerations that
might be taken into account yeah
any comment on that Mr Hawley yeah I'd
agree it's um in with Mr telford's
interpretation of that
um that said we are still not in
agreement on the curtainage of the
dwelling
and whether or not this is lawfully
within the residential Garden
just a just a comment I I always like it
when
parties accept that what the other side
is saying maybe right because I did come
across Witnesses who seem to think it's
their job to disagree with absolutely
everything that's brought up on the
other side and it only weakens rather
than strengthens their case that's
anyway that's not a sign
right
um was there anything more to be said on
that the question of that building thank
you obviously we covered a lot of the
general points in relation to the garage
anyway
so that takes us then to
item three on the agenda and character
and appearance
um now again this is one for the council
and um there needs to be a bit of as a
preamble to the question but
we have local plan policy sdc3 in
particularly paragraph two which says
proposals should be informed by and
sympathetic to the distinctive landscape
areas identified in the
um Derbyshire landscape character
assessment and the areas of multiple
environmental sensitivity
you say the site is in an area for the
primary landscape sensitivity
and the statement of common ground
acknowledges that
um but I was going to ask you where
where I find that designation in the
evidence before me and I know I have
these
two documents that were submitted
yesterday which I haven't looked at in
any group great detail because I wanted
you to sort of point me to the relevant
relevant parts
but that's um
so there's reference to this this area
of primary Landscapes sensitivity if you
just explain that a bit a bit more what
it means in in terms of your policies
the area of primary landscape
sensitivity is set out in the area of
multiple environmental sensitivity
which was produced by Derbyshire County
Council
and that is a county-wide assessment so
let me just I'll just open because I
haven't got a hard copy here I'm just
going to open the document up just bear
with me
just got to find it I've
I filed it and what I thought was an
appropriate place and now I can't see it
um
I'll find it for another route sorry
bear with me
I'm sorry I've seen to have misfiled it
but I'll find it
well I can't I'm afraid I can't give you
my email address
it would actually I'm sorry about I know
I've got it and I've got it
even when you're dealing with hard
copies of things it's amazing how easy
it is to lose something on a disk but I
find it easy easier to lose something on
it
I suspect I suspect he was one of the
old guards
did it have the password as well
I I've just got this feeling that I put
it I put it in a in a folder for inquiry
documents on another case all right I'm
just trying to think about why it's a
cool bit so I can I can um
do a search
isn't reading anything let's just um
sorry about this
right I have I have found found it
attached to the email with police
officer sent paper
and we just
so I'm going to call this
I've already called the document
five
yeah
let me just save that in their
appropriate place when I think about it
[Music]
foreign
support
document I've called inquiry document
for six
right I'm sorry about that right I've
got it I've got them now anyway
so perhaps you could just repeat what
you're saying because I was panicking
about not being able to find the
document I didn't actually say anything
uh so the the
area primary landscape sensitivity Falls
within an area of multiple environmental
sensitivity
um
this is a document produced by
Derbyshire County Council to
characterize areas within the county and
you know Derbyshire is a beautiful
County because this is some incredible
natural assets
and this is a way of classifying areas
within the county in respect to a range
of environmental data sets
so this is set out in the technical
support document how the County Council
has arrived at this characterization
so the primary landscape areas are those
with the highest sensitivity
and which are most likely to be
negatively affected by change or
development
so this is where the landscape remains
intact both visually and structurally
strong historic and cultural identity
contains many widespread semi-natural
habitats if you could just give me the
which part you're reading from here
thank you I will take that thank you
so this is such out in the background
and introduction within the technical
support document so this is
1.0 onwards
thank you
so section 2.5 of the technical support
documents
sets out how the areas are defined are
the areas of multiple environmental
sensitivity would be joined in that
explain how the County Council has
arrived at primary and secondary
okay
so the the area in milsorb is actually
within the Derbyshire Peak for engine
they were doing character
and that's been forwarded
in the
um part one to three garbage repeat for
engine mower doing
supplements which I believe is called
955
so that's set out on a spatial map we're
able to interrogate
the location of an area
running within that map
find out it's a characterization
right so
um this I'm sure it's covered in
Eurovision it just um if you're just
summarizing the key characteristics
so yeah I mean the key characteristics
of of this area I'm not going to go into
in great detail set out in the document
but what is relevant I think to this
case
is its description of the properties and
how they relate to the to the land
so these are dispersed Sandstone
farmsteads with stones Elite moves
buildings constructed of local sandstone
farmsteads dispersed throughout the
landscape
foreign
occasionally clusters of farmsteads and
cottages
so can I just make a point
um as always these policies are broad
brush stroke on the cities that deal
with areas in general obviously you'll
be able to make an assessment of the
impact of these buildings
in the landscape yourself
but the paragraph
1327 of Mr Hall list open says it refers
to views
um a medium and long-term or visible and
medium to long-range views on the valley
side
which means you've got to go across the
valley uh to see
how this these buildings fall into this
the landscape setting not just into the
site itself
and I think you would find it very
difficult to find properties uh of uh
you know that are described by Mr
Worley's son stone with chimneys
um uh and that General character uh in
the vicinity of uh the appeal site uh
the majority of properties I've seen
there are either
replacement dwellings dwellings that
have been substantially extended in
modern materials and modern extensions
including a property up above uh
um Brentwood House On The Higher Ground
uh and the properties in the vicinity of
Ringwood house don't match the
description of properties generally in
this landscape area
but it's also described as a you know an
Auckland undulating ground agricultural
landscape
irregular field patterns bounded by
mixed species hedgerows
networks of binding Lanes
I've done this yeah don't distribute any
of that and they just they're just facts
but what we're talking about is how
those those buildings fit into that
general landscape so so that the
landscape is predominantly agricultural
Rural and pastoral don't dispute that
yeah so you find examples of
agricultural buildings within that
landscape
you
so it's one of those things that uh
you've got the policy there you'll be
able to assess uh the impact of these
buildings on that landscape character
from a medium and long-term views that
uh you know Mr Holloway refers to you've
already mentioned it earlier today as to
these buildings are seen with rising
land behind it
and if you see the character of the
properties it's related to
those properties themselves don't fall
into that description of the typical uh
landscape character
yeah I mean obviously I've noted that
because Mr holy you um
the first thing you mentioned was
dispersed Sandstone Farmstead slate
roofs
um well you know in the immediate
vicinity of this site that's not that's
not what you see but
um I I mentioned earlier on what I'd
seen in my site visit
was there apart from viewing from New
Road was there another vantage point
from the south from which you would say
I get a better appreciation of the
overall landscape and the impact of this
development I think it's fair to say
that the visual impacts in the medium to
long range views have softened
because at the point the notice was
issued there were substantial
oh the point the alleged breach was
being investigated there was a lot of
activity on the land
um which meant that he was more
conspicuous in those medium to
long-range views now those Works have
finished
it temporarily it's not as conspicuous
so I would say that the visual impact of
it is limited there's immediate
surroundings most notably from the roads
to the South as you approach into the
village
and this is just what can be seen
through the summer months the spring and
summer months it may well be different
in the winter and I think Mr Telford
accepts
certainly the intervening vegetation
between the road
and the buildings
isn't going to offer as much screening
during those during the winter and
spring
if any at all
so when you go outside you'll probably
see it at each worst but most most of
the leaves are just about gone
yeah I mean there's still quite a few
well but I've you know I've obviously
taken that into account
yes it is very conspicuous from Johnny
gate which is one of the roads that
comes off New Road
Johnny Gates
now well I've been very often these
these roads like this have got names
locally but you can't find them on a map
anywhere so where where is that
um so you're coming out of millthorpe
um so um Bunny's house is on the left
um it's there's a
Crossroads and it's the one on the right
hand side it is a single track
it it is well known it is it is
signposted Johnny gave and the the road
that runs opposite is called highlightly
just making that to look at that
foreign thank you
right
um
now I mentioned earlier on
the
framework the national planning policy
Frameworks treatment of of valued
Landscapes I mean the first the first
question Mr Hawley is is this would you
say this is a bad new planet it is the
site within a value landscape
I would say it is yes
like I said garbage is a beautiful
County it's well known for its
um incredible natural special qualities
for part of the Peak District national
parks in it
um
and this is an area which has been
designated by Derbyshire County
councilors being an area of primary
landscape sensitivity
this isn't an area of secondary
landscape sensitivity for instance it's
primary
therefore it's one of the most important
to preserve and conserve
so I assume you're referring to section
174 I am yeah
so section 174
[Music]
um
a talks about protecting and enhancing
value of landscapes
so I'm sorry to sort of raise that just
for the first time at the inquiry but of
course it's part of national policy so I
can't ignore it
is that Femme sheltered yes I mean that
type of designation is an indicator I
think of value uh say we're not going to
argue with the 174a value point of
course um what you are dealing with
within that is the uh you know is a
residential situation cartilage and
obviously you'll take that into account
but in terms of the designation that's
uh we acceler that's a marker of value
right is there anything more that
anybody wants to say before we move on
to
four
again I've you know chopped it up into
separate subjects but so we're
um
Mr Telford having heard what you've
heard about the sort of key
characteristics of the area
how do you say the buildings are
sympathetic to the character the
character appearance of the area
um and how do they avoid causing
significant harm in the context of
policy stc3
and how do they protect and enhance in
the context of 174 over the framework
the uh
the buildings are seen in in context
when they looked at from the Vantage
points as to how it affects uh the
character of the area uh their uh
built-in uh traditional uh Oak
uh the oak friend buildings
um they've uh still got the weather and
those buildings will turn silver uh the
garage is already turning as you'll see
on site uh and uh that building is now
starting to blend in uh as with all
buildings including New Stone uh they
stand out for some time until a chance
to weather uh the same applies to these
buildings
uh and uh the design is such that they
will blend into the landscape and have
no impact on its character when viewed
from those Vantage points that uh
you identified and Mr always agreed with
um so they don't adversely affect the uh
the character of the landscape or they
don't adversely affect the character of
uh the middle slope Lane areas
um the long-term viewers you see these
buildings uh interspersed in the
countryside with all the other
Residential Properties the uh between
um uh the top of melsorb Lane and uh the
road at the bottom
um in terms of
uh the uh they whether they uh enhance
the character I can't say that they
enhance the character uh I would suggest
in fact that uh because they're blend in
and they will blend in give them time
uh uh along with a uh the Allen's
intention to landscape his Gardens and
he hasn't had done that yet because of
the works that have been going on
these buildings in fact will uh probably
retain the status quo rather than uh
enhancing but they don't retract from it
uh and that's the way it's been the way
they've been designed
um the intention of the applicant is to
um uh sorry the talent in this case uh
is to put in semi-mature trees uh to
form small pockets of Woodland on his
land
um uh and is it would welcome a
condition uh to the effect that uh the
Landscaping can be submitted uh in due
course should they run the Airfield if
they'd be allowed but the view is they
don't detract from the landscape or the
character of this indispersed pattern of
settlement of pattern of development
along melthorpe Lane
yeah
you think the same story
so if the landscape character assessment
area primary landscape sensitivity
defines these areas as being Sandstone
farmsteads dispersed within the
landscape
it's a pastoral landscape Agriculture
and character
I would expect when you view the land
within the wider landscape you it's
quite clear to see that it's made up of
dispersed farmsteads but also
agricultural buildings
and agricultural buildings are of a
traditional agricultural design
you certain size and shape they are
typical and representative for that area
these buildings are not representative
of any agricultural development
they're not representative of typical
domestic outbuildings either
Oak buildings sorry
thank you yeah Oak buildings although
construction isn't mentioned in the
landscape character appraisal
except that you know the dwellings in
the immediate vicinity May well be
modern
they will have been rebuilt and extended
modestly
they're neatly contained within their
own relatively small cartilage
here we've got particularly the new
garage
some distance from the house and it
relates poorly
to the house
it's the size of a construction
being Timber
which is neither representative of
domestic outbuildings or agricultural
buildings in that landscape
foreign
Timber buildings are more representative
of equestrian type of development
but not on this scale or size
and there's no as far as I'm aware
there's no other examples of such large
domestic outbuildings anywhere within
this locality
so
and it's something that you'll see on
site
um
Stone farm buildings in this particular
locality there may be
there in the wider landscape but in this
particular locality that most of the
agriculture buildings that I'm aware of
normally crinkly tin there rather than
uh traditional Stone and slave the only
ones that I'm aware of are a cartilage
Hall Farm which is up above
um uh beside further up Milton Lane uh
but in fact the recent appeal I attended
uh the stone buildings there were
granted consent over conversion sorry
the word granted consent for conversion
uh but it was indicated they would be
granted consent for residential
conversion uh which would have resulted
in uh the stone uh character having uh
being substantially changed
the majority of farm buildings now and
equestrian buildings now we're built in
profile steel sheeting uh they're not uh
traditional
um uh Stone and slave buildings that
they
idyllic uh picture painted by the
landscape character assessment
I'm I'm not disputing that I wasn't
saying that they are all Stone built the
agricultural buildings I mean
agricultural buildings are functional
you know they're designed to be put up
quickly and as livestock and equipment
and materials they are purely functional
in their design and form
but they are part of an agricultural
landscape
so I'd argue you know crinky tin or
corrugated profile sheeting on
agricultural buildings is part of that
landscape and then the new garage is
simply alien to them
and I say it harms the local
distinctiveness
and it fails to respect the character
and proportions of the surrounding
properties
yeah I don't dispute any of that sir but
uh cricket in buildings aren't
sympathetic to the character of the
character assessment
yeah
I would have suggested that timbertron
buildings like this are far more
sympathetic to a landscope they're in
sustainable materials uh than um profile
steel sheeting sheds
with that contained on working farms
and that and that it gives it an
agricultural and Rural character
where you're building substantial Timber
structures within a domestic context
that is harmful to the landscape
character
ultimately that's the Judgment you
you've got to make we're not copying uh
and we don't need to replicate exactly
what's in the landscape uh for us not to
not to harm and I think that's the size
we put it we are protecting uh for the
purposes of 174a
so you'll have to form a view on the
degree to to which your acceptance or
not
thank you
it lacks any intimate association with
the Drone you know which you would
expect with a domestic carriage
is that that's a comment about the
garage only then obviously it's it's
detached from it uh they uh unfinished
building uh it does have a relationship
uh uh with say the one in which you'll
see when you're on site and when you're
looking at it from a distance
I'd like to go on to the unfinished
buildings and separate matter please
yes
so it's predominantly constructed in
Timber with large areas of glazing bit
of stone cladding
in terms of its design it's an awkward
and odd arrangement of Timber clad
Gables floor decisions can you just slow
down apologies right
I know you're on a roll but
it's the moment
the predominantly Timber with large area
yeah so it's amazing some Stone cladding
large yeah large glazing panels
into floor to ceiling
blazing panels
but it's poor in terms of its design an
odd arrangement of Gables and Dormer
windows
and it's holy alien to the typical
agricultural buildings you're expecting
that landscape
and also it's subordinate incidental our
buildings
just out of interest Mr Tilford
what is it
yes yeah
um
no but what's it what's it for
oh yeah there is mention of it about Jim
it's a extra caraging was it and
Recreation room
it's very good you could go so cars
because that's I've been already
indicated there's a car collection uh it
says classic cars have interested in
expensive sports cars but then the uh Mr
of the the owner of the house is King
golfer so indoor golf range it was what
like a digital
all right top Tracer I was going to say
there's rather too much glass for an
indoor golf range but oh no no no I
don't mean I mean it's for a top top
Tracer which is a
uh expensive digital golf range
obviously you need space to do that and
it's one of those things where you get
augmented realities to be able to play
all duster from the privacy of your
place where you do it that and and the
same Technologies in indoor shooting
range so you've got a uh digital
uh ability to clay shoot inside so that
was the
I did read it
yeah I didn't I didn't know about the
digital yeah golf range but I did yeah
obviously there is a ball to hit but
it's a digital digital thing into where
the internet you know
I have done it I wasn't very good
[Laughter]
slightly disparaging isn't it but yeah I
mean it's it's activities their Hobbies
their hobbies and interests which are
ancillary so that that's the personal
case
well I mean I'd again say that the
design of that building is wholly
inappropriate for garaging I mean
if a garage is genuinely needed then
there are much more sympathetic ways to
provide that garage in without such an
awkward substantial building on that
side
you know if we're looking at its impact
on landscape character and on the host
property
and the type of development which you
see in that area it is harmful
right now Mr Telephone you you put up
defense in relation to the the garage
and the design of that and the way in
which it's sympathetic to the landscape
character I would you do the same in
relation to this building
um
foreign
it's an alleged yeah old school thing
um
now the Gobles were there to to break up
the uh the length of the building rather
than just being one long ridge
um uh so it was it was broken up in that
way but it's a traditional timber frame
building again
uh Timber that will weather down uh and
be similar uh to blend in with its
landscape
windows are always difficult uh
for all intents and purposes a window
from any distance is black it's a it's a
really a hole in the wall
I I accept it when lights are on inside
it takes on a different effect
but the windows are nothing more than
black holes in the wall when it's viewed
from the distance so again the building
has been designed it's close to the
dwelling house so it has got a closer
special relationship with it
and it's been designed and in materials
that the relative is relative to its
landscape rather than being relative to
Brynwood house
foreign
Grace is an interesting point there
about its impact at night and I wanted
not really thought about
um this is a isolated location in an
area of Dark Skies
very very little light pollution in that
area and the impact of that building
when it is actually in use into the
night has got to be harmful
okay
I'm not sure whether it's a designated
Dark Skies area so
um
uh never known that I've never seen that
anywhere in any policy that it's a
designated area for the Dark Skies uh
any Residential Building is going to uh
you know give off light uh like that and
this building is no different to any
other residential extension or
residential
um ancillary building
I'd argue it's different to a an
incidental garage for example where you
wouldn't have such a large window
openings
I'm streaming of course Class C isn't
restricted garaging so um you'd have to
look at the impact of what would be
permitted within classy well that's
that's the incidental use stated by the
opponent
that half of the unfinished building is
a garage I don't think if you look at
the plans it isn't uh on the metrics it
isn't hard I think Mr Tark was the least
language and you look at you look at the
plan we can see the floor plane the uh
the uh the ancillary activities are a
part the hobbies and pastimes which I've
mentioned
foreign
plan you'll see that it's actually just
uh about or under a third
it isn't a half it was that was a miss
loose language
one thing I didn't find out so the the
rules of both of these buildings are in
natural slave
uh so again it's using a natural
material that uh reflects uh the uh
select traditional snake buildings in
the area that are mentioned in the
landscape character
all right thank you
well if we can move on to five
now Mr Telford or Mr hardy can can you
just
be clear about what you say
um a fallback position is against which
I could compare this development
there are two
two parts to it I suppose really the
first is the outside parking
which I've mentioned
so there's no garage in bear in mind
there are no other out buildings
currently or presents for Greenwood
house
um
if the carriage wasn't there then there
are no Outlet links that could be used
for parking vehicles uh so uh all there
is in the cartilage of Brentwood House
at the moment is the property itself uh
so it's not as though uh it's repeating
buildings are already there this is the
first time a garage is being built apart
from the original one which we were
going to talk about is the lodge
um but this is uh the only outbuilding
that exists uh that's the garage uh if
that wasn't there then all the vehicles
and there are a lot of them all the
vehicles would be parked in the open so
that's the one of the fallback positions
and that opened that open parking would
have uh more detrimental effect on
the character and openness of the
landscape then this well-designed
building would would do
the second part of it is uh the fallback
position regarding classy buildings
uh we would have still retains it's
classy committed development rights
and buildings the reason for these
buildings requiring content is their
their height
um uh but uh
um also the fact that they're forward in
front of the phone most part of
Brentwood has
there'll be no reason why uh this
important friend building or this uh
Timber friend building uh couldn't be
adapted
move behind the front elevation of
Brentwood house uh and erected us
committed development
uh can I just refer back to
uh the letter I wrote uh to
um Mr Purcell who's the deputy I think
is the deputy director of planning
uh suggesting and making on site
uh and at that time without prejudice we
offered to
withdraw the appeal or the launch
can I just stop you that I think that
this is the correspondence that I was
referring to was spawning and that was
the answer me and I've sent that to Mr
Lee there
um it may be if I wasn't aware if you
wanted to refer to that whether actually
you do need a copy of that and if so
um it was it was an email that went to
the council so it might be helpful to
put that in
if I'm the only one that's not a secret
and I feel very left out yeah I mean
maybe maybe get you a copy printed over
lunch but do you want do you want to
just explain what was it the the letter
uh offered to mate on site uh and
without prejudice I said yeah I
suggested that we would draw the appeal
for the launch which will now
subsequently done but that could have
been done at that time
um uh they uh classy building uh The
Unfinished building will be removed and
moved behind before the most part of
bring one house as a classy building and
adapted accordingly so he met all the
size and height parameters
uh and the council would withdraw their
objection to the garage
uh so we tried to uh agree to move the
class are they unfinished building
um uh at that meeting and it was refused
outright
uh I understand
um Mr hardy also
approached uh Council for the council uh
and suggested a similar situation
um but again that that was refused well
this Mr hardy suggested
in relation to this uh
sorry
um
so that was a suggestion that we made
and that making us refused but
the suggestion to move the classy
building back out are the unfinished
building back as part of Class A uh and
the fallback position was turned down
um but uh moving that building which
would be a very expensive exercise it
could be done uh and still make the
requirements of classes so that's a
fallback position that I was referring
to as well
so that's moving that building but the
garage to remain yes okay
okay and in terms of putting that in a
legal context I know I'm sure you know
but that's Manson and Tom Bridge which
is the that's uh uh Lord Justice Lynn
Blanc Gordon appeal and just to
summarize that that uh what Justice
Limbaugh had to say basic print support
is that for a prospect to be a real
Prospect uh it doesn't have to be
probable or likely possible possibility
will suffice more than a theoretical
possibility exactly and then there's no
rule of law that in every uh case real
Prospect Depends for example on the site
having been allocated
uh or planning permission granted or
indeed on there being a firm design for
an alternative scheme or the landowner
or developer having said precisely how
you'd make use of those PD rights in
some cases that degree of clarity and
commitments necessary with the times
it's not
um and just applying those principles
hits obviously a matter for you uh to
attach weight to to it but the evidence
that has been given in relation to the
expense that's gone into this build and
the materials
um the appellant is not going to waste
275 grams worth of bespoke would he's
going to there will be an application or
a for a clopid US it would be my advice
but there will be a PD
and classy building
so it very much is a real Prospect
thank you very much
so I referred to uh companies
I was just giving a little bit a little
bit more more flesh on the outside and
you know in terms of characterization
there is a clear desire on the part of
this Landover to develop and maximize
the value of those people
so this email correspondence
is document 10.
a copy of um uh
of Manson Tumblr they don't know whether
I need to whether you've got your own
version of that
while I'm unaware of it
um would you like it would you like I
mean
I suppose all right can we get one of
those over lunch to you yeah
right so can I just um respond briefly
to that point you've got the email in in
front of you which is which is self
um explanatory repellents are specific
questions
um and this is um
the date of email it's it is well into
the appeal
um after proofs have been
um
exchange Mr personal it was completely
reasonable in this episode to say well
this this isn't we're happy to respond
to your questions which he does your
points but a meeting isn't going to take
us uh forward the castle under no
obligation uh to to meet and and for the
reasons Mr Purcell explains
um it's fairly reasonable not to meet
um as to this fallback position this is
dealt with and in fact it's the main
point in Mr hawley's rebuttal proof and
uh so you you'll have seen that sort of
um refer you explicitly
uh to that
um the point is the Council of disputes
that these buildings um could be built
up under permissive development rights
uh some of these arguments are within
the old ground scene
um
appealed I mean that you know for one
they're too hot they're too high they
they don't come within the height
restrictions of uh class
um e and and there's a range of other
arguments and Mr hawley's uh proof um as
well and one of which is relevant to
consider when
um to turning the ground area is that
the appellant could exercise is
permissive development rights in any
event uh so you would end up with not
two buildings but four buildings in the
Green Building
um and and that is also relevant uh
material uh consideration
um
all those points are set out in Mr
Holly's yeah I mean I've just heard the
whispering but yeah the suggested
conditions include the removal of PD
rights right well that but that that's
something you would need to um uh
consider uh but even but even so as as a
fallback that relies on PDFs not within
the cartilage
um those buildings couldn't be built
under PD
um one of the um uh buildings are um
are um
it will it certainly looks unfinished
um and it's only been suggested today
for the first time that it is finished
uh or all of these things and the other
points made by
um this Mr Julio are relevant it isn't
the straightforward cases as advanced by
independent that these bodies could
simply be transposed and built under PD
rights they couldn't
I'm going to think the high point is
acknowledged and obviously the position
in relation to the principle elevation
is uh knowledge it's just in in
assessing
like as you say uh Mr hardy the question
is whether it's more than a theoretical
possibility but the question is what is
it so in terms of in terms of assessing
attributing weights to the fullback
position I've got to have a reasonably
clear idea about what could be could be
built and at the moment it's
buildings which are
incidental provided for purposes
incidental to the enjoyment of the
dwelling house but meet the restrictions
in the gpdo including that they are
within the cartilage which is a disputed
a disputed issue so
um as I said what I'm what I'm trying to
be clear of is um
what am I comparing with am I comparing
what I can see with a no alternative yes
so I mean you're absolutely right you've
got a a question to ask about Curtis if
you know that you've seen the evidence
that they would have to be within Curtis
but we we're assuming that's right then
the advice to Clark the instruction from
the client very clearly is that he wants
to would seek to maximize
the um PD rights that he's got within
Class E so that means before you know
fulfilling all the qualifying criterias
of instant or to reuse but also the
metrics now the the metric on this
building uh which is troublesome if you
go for the height one this building can
be modified so it's not a straight
transposition of this building
uh onto another part of the site that
would have to be modification but
because again what I don't have is
expert evidence on that on the the um
the possibility of modifying that
building to bring it within the PD
limits I'm going to be instructed this
week this week but what what I what I've
said is that you you would need to make
sure that all of the requirements were
done what I'm told because of the nation
it says it's wood you can do that so I I
need to be what
sorry so what did you just say
what I said was that I just repeat
myself say that um so instructed this
week so took instructions yesterday from
the client what I said to the client was
you would have to clearly make sure that
you meet all the qualifying criteria and
the metrics so in terms of height and
its original
and because of the materials because it
would because the this was produced by
an outfit called Oak rights for a
specialist in this type of construction
you could cut you could lower the height
so it's not a case of you have to show
the entire body you can modify this
building
and therefore the the evidence that's
put forward is no there's no final
design but it would be a design which
maximized The Classy
PD rights and fulfilled all of the
criteria that is the
that is the position
may I have some help with with a legal
issue
and that is
um
so Ground grand e has gone to which this
question of current religion
sorry ground C think of classy ground C
has gone to which this the issue of
cartilage was Central
um
now the issue occursive it is only
relevant to the fallback position
to what extent is it appropriate in me
for me in this appeal to say this is the
cartilage you know as opposed to it
being a ground sea of people or a
significant lawfulness application
um because you've you've indicated that
your advice to the accountable for you
to put in a a lawful development
certificate application and then the
council will be able to consider and
formally answer that question about what
is the cartilage and if they were an
appeal somebody probably not me would
um would be able to make that decision
but I'm just I I often have this this
issue but I'm just not always sure about
the extent to which I should be saying
that is the curtisage and therefore this
would be permitted development just just
I'm rambling a bit but just just just to
go on Just for just for a moment the way
I see it is this
I would have to
I have to attribute weight to a fallback
if I have some except there's a fallback
position I have to attribute weight to
it
so as I said I've had to think about
well what is it that could be built as
part of that I have to think about well
would it be within the cartilage but the
most I can do is say well
um I think it probably would be but I
wouldn't be making a a formal
determination about that and I might be
wrong but I think that that's fine
because what what you there is obviously
occur to it the extent of the cartilage
is in in dispute
what you can say is that and and the the
evidence from the opponents is that
there is an intention to maximize those
PD rights of the Class E So within
whatever that uh cartelage is there
would be building of those proportions
and I think to that extent you can say
um you know I can't say exactly where
that will be and for present purposes I
don't need to make a definite ruling as
to the you know the line on the ground
as to where the cartilage is but I know
enough
that there is a there is a currency
which this building into which and given
the size of this building it's the size
of the house there's no question there
would be real within a cartilage on any
basis that would accept the size of this
building
so I think our invitation is not to say
that you needed to rely on the ground
but to you can attribute
uh substantial weight to the fall back
on that basis
so I hope that's
helpful it gets you out of our I think a
need to to draw a line on the ground
that would be a matter of the problem as
you say
just yes just a moment
yes thank you
so and just to um
repeating myself my little friend stage
well
um it's relevant to cons to consider
cartilage because uh buildings of this
size could be accommodated within the uh
cartilage of course we say that it
couldn't because they're too big uh
that's um that's really that's that's a
relatively small point but just to
correct that
yeah yeah
um in terms of in the the relevance of
uh cartelage so I'm Keen to make this as
straightforward for you as possible
um however if if you were to accept that
these buildings were for
incidental they're incidental to the
dwelling house now I don't mean in terms
of Class E uh for now but just
considering the ground day appeal that
these are essentially domestic art
buildings uh let's call them that
um if the appendant is trying to develop
domestic outbuildings beyond the
domestic cartilage that is going to have
to carry weight for the ground a uh
appeal
um so the way um you might deal with
this is of course the opponent bringing
uh the appealers for them to uh make out
their appeal uh to say that you're not
persuaded by the insufficient evidence
has been provided that the buildings are
within the domestic cartilage
um and and that has to be in my
submission relevant material
consideration
and we we can of course go into the
question of cartilage it's in the
evidence anyway it obviously it's
covered in some some detail in there
yeah but there is a real
um risk of guard and grabbing as as it
was put a slightly grubby word on it
um and it's it it seems to me it's it's
perhaps not necessary for you to go into
cartilage in detail
um but it isn't entirely irrelevant
because what they're saying is they want
you to come to the view that you're not
persuaded in the reviews that means
engaging with the evidence obviously uh
we say the opposite it is privilege
you've got the evidence and if that's
what the council wants you to do then I
suspect that's uh his drawing a line
I my suggestion was that you didn't need
to go there but if if you accept the
council's proposition then you do you've
got the evidence you'll have to form the
view but I don't think you do
so there's one other point I'd like to
um
yes just before you do it just you know
just to make it make it clear I it's not
that I sort of duck responsibility but I
often um you know I'm aware that my role
in in the planning system is a limited
one it's one
determining matches which are before me
not not tying the hands of the local
planning Authority I'm not the local
planning Authority on other matters
which are not strictly
strictly before me
um and um
I think expected to have to be wary
about what they they say in their
decisions that go beyond the strict
roommate of the appeal that's all does
that mean I'm cautious of making this
more complicated
um even as a barrister then then it
needs to be
um but
um if you were to Grant planning
permission
for domestic buildings
and then to say well I'm not sure
whether it's Cottage or not and I don't
need to determine that
that seems to me that that's that that
would be a difficult situation for you
to be in
right well well
um
if if I grow up planning permission it's
got nothing to do with committed
development rights exactly so this is
just moving away from the permissive
development considering so granting
planning permission for domestic
buildings beyond the domestic cartilage
um is in my submission problematic
hmm
I don't want to get too bogged down in
in
um
theoretical legal points but but it's
it's quite an interesting one because if
if it was just if it was just a
section 78 appeal against refusal of
planning permission
um I'm not sure that I'd necessarily be
looking to to determine what the
curtainage was before I determined
whether I grant planning permission
because I mean the whole thing is
complicated because cartilage anyway
it's relevant to planning but like
curtadich is not a use of a use of land
but if I granted planning permission for
a domestic outbuilding then by virtue of
doing that these planning for the use
that's associated with that that
building
so essentially you'd be extending the
cartilage yeah but so what well
if I find the buildings acceptable yeah
and with it and with that goes the the
associated use okay I've extended the
cursage but I say cursive user is just
something which I have to consider in in
relation to permitted development rights
that's about that's a concept PD I agree
yeah and it'd be I suppose there's a
potential rationality point there you
know why you know why would it be
necessary to
extend the cartilage by the back door as
it would but instead of extending the
cursive it's not what the planning
system isn't about about defining the
cartilage it may be necessary to find
the cursors in order to determine
whether there are committed development
rights but
um you know what is the cartilage is a
matter of fact yeah but I I suppose to
look at its um
um to stand back from the particular
facts in this case so we we've all seen
cases where you've got uh somebody's
domestic property or garden and then
what's clearly an agricultural field
beyond the garden and when they start
trying to build domestic Garden type
outbuildings in the agricultural field
that is plainly a problem
um and if an inspector just
allowed building aggregate you know
domestic buildings within the
agricultural field
um the policies would be entitled to the
council will be entitled to ask well why
you know what's the basis for allowing
that yeah that's a different point isn't
it well it's the same point well I mean
I've started it yeah so it's my fault
but
we'll continue for too long but the
point I think the point is if if if
there is if somebody's building or
proposing to build something outside of
what was what may have been the
curtainage the reality is I'm looking at
is that building acceptable in planning
terms and it will be acceptable in
planning terms if it doesn't accept the
harm a character pretty much the area
whatever
the fact that it is or isn't inside the
cartilage is not really relevant to that
it's what is the impact in planning
terms yeah of extending the domestic
area that would be yes yeah
um but I'm granting planning permission
for a building in that location I'm not
granting planning permission for the
extension of a cursory so I think
everyone's agreed on that I mean often
that that's the way it's described I
think enforcement notices which talk
about the extension of the Curtis
um it's very easy but I'll just as I say
I just want to make sure that I don't um
in my decision overstep the mark of what
it is I should probably be considering
but it's um
yeah so there's one other point if I may
move on from Cutlass you may be grateful
for
me be doing so
um there's another point about the class
e
um you need to be satisfied as well when
considering the fallback position for
the buildings the use of the buildings
is incidental to the use of the um
dwelling house
um we've heard a little bit more about
the use of the buildings uh today one
one point
um
which has been said a few times by the
appendages well you know we could park
as many cars
um as we're like and there's been
reference to lots of cars
um there of course has to be a limit
to the number of cars
uh which are incidental to
um the use of the dwelling now just
about reasonable exactly so so a larger
dwelling um will permit
um a larger number of cars
um it's normal for somebody to use their
outbuilding to
um
keep their stamp collection or other uh
Past Times a large collection of classic
cars
um is is testing that uh bound
boundaries
I mean not at all it's a classic car
collection it is actually an archetypal
uh classy
building and I think there's a
distinction to be drawn between kind of
domestic cars you know things which are
driven every day and those which are
very high value track cars uh vintage
cars and and this owner has a collection
of not just things to drive on the road
but things which are not driven on the
robot which are very valuable vintage
high performance which you will see so
yeah as I said I think that we can't get
go much further to say it's it's got to
be reasonably reasonably incidental and
so I would predict this again I say
these things that you can tell me if I'm
wrong but I I would say a garage to
house a collection of of classic cars is
in principle something which is capable
of being incidental to enjoyment as well
as us if you've got three thousand
classic cars then you know they're
Drawing the Line is a difficult thing
um but I think what you're doing it's
not black and white it's not it
definitely is incidental but it's
capable so when we see some of the
things that have been accepted as being
reasonably incidental this is something
which is capable of being reasonably and
that to me is all you need to do because
we're not determining whether or not
this building would you know is always
is with is not within Class E what we're
saying is in the fallback that you could
have a compliant classy building which
would be of a use that's ancillary two
and fours within the qualifying criteria
we're saying absolutely you can that is
subjecting the testing testing of that
and of course my recommendations of the
client would be to put a Clockwork into
give the clutch into the council
a view on that before we um before he
set to work
that's enough is that what he said a
decided
foreign
foreign
yeah I mean I've just done that score
when I go on site because I've been told
basically you can just chop off
chop off the uh part of the timber frame
I've got to look at that and say well if
you chop up two meters of this timber
frame and you're not altering the roof
and all the rest of it is that going to
work so I mean I'd be looking at that on
on site or you oh you're gonna have to
like lie on the floor and roll into the
building
suggest it might not work for an indoor
golf simulator
if you're playing in between in the
frame
and so just further on to the fallback
argument so we've got no
um
yeah so this is set out in 6.3 for my
rebuttal 6.23 sorry
we've got now we have evidence of an
incidental use other than garaging
from a suggestion of an incidental use
of engaging
but we have now we have now yeah
there's no information on the ground
conditions as to where this building
might go
site constraints
practicality of building in a different
location
nor have we got any details on the
amount of engineering work that might be
required
to prepare the land
or that that would fall within the scope
of Class E
so my viewing has set out in 6.25 it's
the fallback attract very limited weight
and it's insufficient to demonstrate
very special circumstances
foreign
[Music]
case very far because what we're saying
is that you uh need to take a view you
apply weight to whether or not there can
be a qualifying classy building we don't
need to provide details ground
conditions and distracts or any of that
sort you've just gotten satisfied
according to uh or Justice lindblum
there is a real possibility what we're
telling you is that yes as I've said as
I've said that's all I need to be
satisfied of to take account of a
fallback position but in terms of the
weight that I attached to form that
position these uncertainties are
relevant
uh well to the extent that that you need
to get into that but what we're not
doing is putting a particular building
before what we're saying is that you'd
max out the PD rights under Class E and
that would be looked at at that stage so
you know it you
I suppose wait
could be increased if you'd got plans
and so on but I don't think that's a a
major Point um because of the nature of
the materials and the uh in you know the
clear intention of the opponent to max
out the PD rights
I'm not sure I can tell you much for
that I think we're
we've said what we need to to say on it
all right thank you
right
foreign
it's already been touched on and this is
slightly off topic really in terms of
the the agenda but it's already been
touched on but this the question of the
The Unfinished building or the finished
building whatever it actually is
um as I understand it
the the position is that
even an unfinished building in in theory
I could Grant planning permission for an
unfinished building the the question is
is it acceptable is it appropriate to do
so given any harm that might result from
being an unfinished building
beyond that there's this issue about
what could be done and when I say
unfinished I'm talking about as at the
time of the enforcement notice
um but then the question is well
if if
um planning permission were granted for
an unfinished building could it be
finished by carrying out Works which
do not constitute development
development yes those are that's what
I've got to
consider really is there anything more
that anybody wants to say on that issue
um
people
um now
I think this wasn't an issue questions
um the um the accountancy said well
forgive me my microphone wasn't on in
fact I'm just going to get up if it's in
here
section 55 so I'm not relying on my
ever failing memory
um
so section 55 2
the following operations or uses of land
shall not be taken for the purposes of
this act involved development of the
land but carrying out the maintenance
Improvement or other alteration of any
building of Works which affects
only the interior or the building
or do not materially affect the external
appearance
of the building
um and we don't need to worry about war
damage and so on so it might be helpful
just to have a photograph in front of
you which remember that paragraph 6.3 of
Mr all his proof
5.5 close on page eight
it's it's really work it's all having a
look at that
um
yes
um
what what we can see there is a building
with uh bits of sheeting it looks like
random bits of wood
um some
black strips and random bits of stone in
the middle of it
um
now
to be slightly flipping I'm sure we've
all seen words of tape modern
um it doesn't look finished the
appellants are said with a straight face
that it is finished uh
I I think so you are entitled to form a
view
um as to whether or not this building is
well apart from anything else you've got
you've just got block work on
the right hand side
um is that how it's intended to remain
partly Stone cloud and partly exposed
these blocks well no I don't it doesn't
I don't mean finished as in everything
has been done all like eyes and T's but
the point is you've got to have a
material effect so in terms of what you
can do to finish this without the need
for consent that's that you know
nobody's going to suggest this is the
finished it depends like what you mean
by finish is it exactly as it's intended
to be but of course it isn't but in
terms of finished for the purposes of a
planning legislation you've got to look
at materiality of a family say that it
is finished for Section 55 pills well um
I think yeah I mean there's another
danger here you know we can confuse
different things like the question of
when when is something substantially
completed compared to what can be done
to it that doesn't materially affect the
external appearance because I mean a
substantially completed building is one
which is a a fully detailed building
um but as I said that's that's a
different issue there is a building
there the question is what could be done
to that building that wouldn't
materially to finish it off if you like
which would not materially affect the
external
I think so may I suggests the way of
dealing with this is when you're
considering the impact on Greenbelt and
other landscape Palm
um yes uh you can take into account your
parents can carry out internal works but
those internal Works can't materially
affect the exterior of the building so
when you're assetting the impact of this
building uh you need to look at the
exterior of the building as it is in
that
uh
if you photograph
um if if the appellant can introduce
internal works that don't materially
impact on the exterior uh good luck to
them
um but no doubt the council will be um
wanting to go and have a look when
they've done it
uh the other thing okay I can form a
view on the likelihood of the
probability of something happening but I
can't I can't require it
so I I suppose I've got to work on the
basis that it may just stay as is
that make well I mean I suppose I I can
form of you unlikelyhood but it may it
could remain as it is I can't I can't
make the opponent do anything to it no
no you can't what you do though have is
evidence it isn't going to stay like you
know it will be finished uh in terms and
finished as in finished off the
finishing touches and and what Mr early
that has said it isn't quite right
because it's not the internal matters so
far as they go into effect the extra
externality any changes have got to be
material changes so you've got the the
correct question is
um
and we say that you can finish this
building can be finished off without the
need for planning permission within
section 54. there's nothing before you
to show how that could possibly be done
a matter of you to attach away to
foreign
Common Sense point but if you approved
what was there then of course there
could be a planning application to if
the council was right so if they if they
uh insisted on those Works having a
material effect on external externality
that you could do that
and there was also that point in Arnold
I'm not I'm not
urging it on you but
um one option is is a class G oh sorry
it's ground G where there is a Time
given for uh
for an application of that sort now I
don't think that's necessary here
because for the reasons I uh indicated
that I just wrote it
okay now
I said I've probably stop around one
o'clock but they also said I get carried
away you'll see that I do
um just in terms of overall progress
that this isn't any criticism of anybody
because if anything it's down to me the
questions I ask and further questions
that I asked but
um
we're certainly not going to finish with
him we haven't finished with him the
anticipated two hours we've still got a
fair amount
uh to do
um plus the the site inspection
um which obviously I need to do in
daylight and we don't have a huge amount
of daylight left
um when we've got to have lunch as well
I I don't at this point see a great
benefit in having the site visit before
we finish the rest of the discussion I
think it would be better to finish the
discussion and then have the site visit
tomorrow yeah
so that that leaves open the questions
to what to do about closing submissions
and business applications from our point
of view
um you've you've got a note it's a
Roundtable discussion it's effectively a
hearing uh we're happy to do everything
already at the end of the day rather
than needing to come back tomorrow but
if it would assist you to Aboriginal
closing submissions
um those could be done overnight yeah I
mean it's not so much about the written
closing submissions it's more about
and when I've been on
that will informed but when I hear what
you've got to say that maybe there may
be questions and so on which arise out
of my my site in inspection so I I'd
rather not hear closing submissions and
then go on site and think I wish I'd
been able to ask this or that so you'd
rather have crazy suspicions after I
would prefer that I realize that has
practical consequences but you were
expecting to be here too absolutely yes
um so
um I would rather do it that way
um just as I interrupted the opening
submissions within seconds if you start
I do I do like to get the full value out
of council and make sure I've fully
understood what you said by asking
questions and say that that's that's
special if it's informed by site
inspection as as well that the side
effect of that is that it may give you
the opportunity to put closing
submissions
it's always a matter of learning a
friend I mean do you need closing
submissions I'm not in a sense that I'm
not forcing you no no but given where we
are this is an RTS within an inquiry
format it seems to me that uh actually
this discussion
in in effect this telescopes doesn't it
down to something akin to an informal
hearing you wouldn't have had Rose of
sufficient at the end of that
you've got the evidence
unusually in my experience so
I I'm I'm just floating whether or not
in fact you need them and what I've seen
is I'm not sure we can add to the
evidence that's actually been given well
what I would say on that is I can't
force anybody to make those exhibitions
it's not uh um whether I need them or
not I can't judge until I've heard them
you see what I mean but the use I always
look forward to closing submission
sometimes I'm disappointed but um
um it's a matter if you were both just
if you were to both say to me would you
not intend to make closing submissions
I'm not going to say well I'm afraid you
must do unless I've got specific
questions that I want you legal points
that I want you to to address but um if
if either of you intends to make closing
oh we've got the costs as well yeah
and get within writing but it can be but
um
both saying is that if I don't speak
English to leave it but if there is a
way of
um of not coming back tomorrow I mean
greatest to respect that would be great
but oh yeah of course we shall be here
uh as I said I'm not going to force you
to make closing submissions if you don't
want to but um well it's assuming that
you would be wanting to yeah okay
in that case we'll be back tomorrow
um
yeah
I've got no burning desire today because
I think all we're going to do is repeat
evidence that you've taken a full no
time anyway so yeah I I don't see it
really is a case where closings are
going to help you but I'm happy to pull
them in writing if you want
well as a I can't force you to give
closing submissions made Collision
submission B I can't force you to put
them in writing either it's an inquiry
less than four days so the rules don't
um don't actually say they should be in
writing but
usually what happens is you'll write
them out anyway before you make the
sunlight I just will have them
um if you've got them right it just
makes it easier for me when it comes to
taking notes but it's a matter for both
of you if you make it easy for you so
I'm very happy to do closing submissions
the the last final question then is is
what to do about the um
the the cost application I think the
council will slightly vary its uh cast
that well I'll take further further
instructions on the Gen generally but
certainly the ground D
um they didn't need to wait until one
minute to tend to with withdraw it
that's we probably wouldn't have come
here if they'd done it a few weeks ago
we could have dealt with it all in a
different way
um
that has caused it additionally so so so
the cost application will be modified to
a certain extent the question is then
um
the council will want the opportunity to
respond to that whether we just deal
with that orally
or whether it needs to be in writing is
is is probably a matter of use of I'm
quite happy for I mean obviously in many
many cases cost applications are oral
and it's actually more common than it is
to deal with everything in in writing
um
yes I don't know whether this works but
it why can we not do the through the
evidence then have even if it
take takes half an hour you're not going
on site today it doesn't matter why
can't represent submissions today even I
I vote for orally do the cost
applications uh you know uh with a A or
oral submissions today we don't have to
come back tomorrow you go on your site
visit if there's times if there's time
we can do that but the the my
um concern there is that if closing
submissions are today
um they won't be in writing no and and
and and and you said that risen
submissions would so I think it's if
written submissions would assist you
then I'd ask that those are given
tomorrow
um if you're happy with oral submissions
uh then um it wasn't for me
for me it wasn't so much a question of
whether they're oral written it's a
question of whether they're before or
after and you prefer to either site
visit that's that's the point that's why
yeah
in that case that will give us time
overnights to resume closing Solutions
yeah
um
and if we could deal with costs or early
tomorrow yeah as well
I mean I I think costs are different
because Normal the procedure would be to
have written response in costs that's
obviously a matter of some concern so I
would want to see uh and I want to take
care over what I say in that uh I I
think would would I don't think pleasure
submission needs to be where I might
talk about today but the league that
aside
um in a cost application if that's
modified I would like that some writing
and I would like the opportunity to
respond in writing and I think I think
seven days would be the sensible way to
do that I don't want to respond on the
hoop
well um we've it's only going to be
slightly modified and I've said how it's
going to be modified and only friends
plenty of time to think about that it's
it's really whether the guarantee appeal
should have been withdrawn earlier
um he's got 24 hours to think about that
and take instructions he ought to be
able to deal with that already it's very
normal for costs applications to be made
and responded to actually on on if only
because
um they they may be prompted by
something that happens during the course
of the inquiry rather than something
that haven't happened before but what
the way I would deal with that is
when they just talk about this but the
way I do deal with that is if we have if
we're having a site deal with all the
other matters all the other evidence
today have the site visit tomorrow
morning there's then an opportunity to
consider
um to to finalize closing submissions
um
if you put them in writing that's great
if you don't well I can't criticize you
for that
um and there is an opportunity to think
about costs but if having heard what the
fantas have to say about it you say to
me I need more time to consider that and
I could make that Judgment at the time
depending on what Mr Luther said if it's
nothing more than than what he's already
said which you must have anticipated
um
well yes I mean but the response to that
if it is simply ground deep it's just
the removal of that I mean it's a very
easy response uh which I will put in
writing but it's you know it's Miss
conceived
he's done it already doesn't it
I was expecting something rather
different at being honest because at the
moment the application the cost is a
partial wall and it's based on the the
cost 6th of September so I I if the
council is simply going to stick by that
modify it in relation to ground D fair
enough it's very simple
um
well the
I know you've got views on it but the
application for course talks about
obviously that what happened on the 6th
of September but it also says that the
the ground a appeal had no problem that
takes us through to the inquiry of
course
to be a partial application obviously I
can only respond to what the councilors
have sought and it's a partial order Cut
yeah but there's partial because it
doesn't include ground death not not
because it stops at the sickness of
always first first of November actually
but
you've got my respect up and what I've
done is responded to the council's
application uh and I've done that
carefully so if if the council is simply
going to say that it's about uh removal
of um appeal a fair enough that's
straight forms and straightforward
credit ground but that isn't what they
said it's not what we said
that I have got the what I've got was a
written application cost
that sets out a number of bases and that
comes to an application have a look at
the the learning of the application
so it comes to
uh paragraph 22 for the reasons as well
the opponent's conduct in these appeals
has been unreasonably numerous respects
and justifies a partial yes of all the
costs on procedure and substantive
ground
so if all that's being added to that is
a point today about withdrawal of appeal
Aid so the ground D fair enough and
that's a straight that's a
straightforward Point unless I'm being
done
the question was whether whether whether
the partial application because related
purely to the waisted because of the
first day or whether they they relate to
all the costs relating to ground a and
and for the avoidance yeah yeah well yes
and for the advantage of that we're
talking about right up until the end of
the inquiries and it doesn't stop on the
date of the occupation and I can make
that experience
so paragraph eight I mean the council
makes its application and and I've
responded and I'll respond to anything
which is put in further but eight
councils applying for a water costs and
respect to work undertaken to date in
relation to the appeal by office and
Council and advisor preparing an inquiry
Drafting and reviewing peer
documentation errors as well as other
Administration costs in relation to the
aborted inquiry that set on 6th of
September 2022. that's how it's ranked
foreign
resources considering whether buildings
sorry
confusion
is the application in outline that sets
out what the application is before it
goes into the detail I've got the
different versions
that's the version I I was saying that's
perhaps we can um this year different
versions splitting around that's Mr
Hawley can
check what was sent I mean Mr Hawley
sent me the application so I'm dealing
number one that the council sent me
something else well there's some perhaps
it's probably me that's got it wrong but
we could have lunch and discuss it over
lunch and then
work out what we're going to do
well unless it's really going to resolve
it quickly but you see but but just make
sure again make sure I've got the same
paragraph 13 talks about
um the appeals being unusually weak
yeah
um
18 says the appeal underground a further
has no reasonable prospects of success
yeah 17 dealt with ground C
and the and 21 says the unreasonableness
of dependent in the Box in the ground
further justifies the substantive Award
of costs
um yeah
and then he says for these reasons
uh possible is Justified
the 6th of September yeah well I I don't
agree with you obviously that that if
that's right
so making the response as you'll see is
that this is poorly written application
because not leaving aside the contact
but paragraph
uh the the occupation you know overall
it's an overarching paragraph So that
sounds 22 which is the conclusion
well yeah
what
this application is paragraph to my
reading paragraph
isn't being consistent with paragraph
It's a partial application and paragraph
8 says that that is in relation to the
abortion climate 6th of September if
that's wrong and the council want to go
beyond that of course that's their right
but I would then want to have a
um you know the opportunity to respond
to that properly all right but
um 22 talks about
um
an award both on procedural and
substance
[Music]
yes
it's up to the council to set stuff but
what they're saying is that you
shouldn't have got to that hearing on
6th of September because
you've got no prospects of success a
procedural and substantive ground Mount
to a partial award that's my
understanding they're not inconsistent
yeah
I've got numbers uh restart uh in terms
of of the rest of it is absolutely clear
um
um
there we have it all I want to know I
think the important thing is I want to
know what account says and given uh
what's just been said I don't I don't
want to deal with that you know quickly
because there is yeah
I would like the opportunities
all right
and then then
whether you you but you can tell me
whether you think you need more time and
I can and I can uh consider that but
often you know the extra time that's
that's allowed for across yeah
I mean usually yeah
but the reason I would agree to the
response costs being dealt with in
writing
because there isn't time to deal with it
the inquiry if there is normally I deal
with it and it just adds costs on to
both of our clients and
anything
yeah well as I say I mean
all right
yeah
see I don't I don't see what
every other inspector I don't spend my
time sitting up with other inspectors
but I've been doing
20 years so I know what I do
so your experience is my experiences
okay quite hungry
but um
how long would you like we haven't got
very we can't there's not really where
we can go let's go I've got I've I've
brought some I bought some sandwiches
this morning anticipating this problem
so I've got them in my car but how long
bearing in mind you've got to go
somewhere else how long would you like
for actually we are going to Tesco's I
wasn't joking so
um half an hour 40 minutes what time is
it now well it's it's near it's sort of
12 13 minutes should we say half past
perfect half past two
well thank you very much for adjourning
until then